and around the country
c-span is brought to you by your cable
or satellite provider
[Music]
and now on book tv we're live with
best-selling author and journalist david
corn
mr corn is the author or co-author of
six books including blonde ghost the
lies of george w bush and most recently
russian roulette the inside story of
putin's war on america and the election
of donald trump
during the next three hours it's your
chance to talk with david corn via phone
social media and email
david corn you've been in washington a
long time
what's your take on the last two years
um god uh
it's harder you know to to
have an overview because we live so much
in the moment to moment that may be one
of the biggest changes that we've had
with this president with this
administration that it seems to be
crisis
or
tweet every every hour
you keep wondering how many more wheels
are there to come off the bus and we've
had a total breakdown
in political discourse
and you know any degree of cooperation
even in the in the sense of reasonable
government governance i mean having
lived here
you know through you know reagan years
and then uh you know george w h bush
years in george w bush years when i as a
progressive had a lot of issues
with the policies that they were
pursuing whether it was the iraq war the
reagan tax cuts there was still a
semblance of
you know i don't want to be overly
you know dewey eyed about this of people
working together
tip o'neill and reagan having a beer and
that's that's not what i'm talking about
i'm talking about the sense that people
on both sides still believe they could
have a policy debate an honest debate
and sort of slug it out
people win and lose and then you move on
and there was some concern
for the
overall value
of keeping things
working and moving and
and respect for the processes even if
they didn't always work out to your
advantage
um and i think we've seen a a total
breakdown that began a little bit before
trump i think the merrick garland
fight which wasn't even a fight was
really a
gigantic step
in one party saying to another party
we're not going to play by those rules
anymore we're going to be
as obstructionist as possible
and use every loophole we can find and
then trump coming in and having really
no concern
for any
position any side any person that really
is not
is not himself and i feel it's
hyperbolic to say this
but he does you know
act as if he's a narcissist who cares
not a wit for the opinions or even for
the facts brought to him by anybody else
and you just see this again and again
and again from people who leave and the
information that leaks out in his own
behavior he shows no regard for anybody
else other than himself and if you're
not with him you're a hater you know he
you know he lies incessantly glenn
kessler the fact checker at the
washington post now has them up to seven
thousand
misrepresentations false statements some
of them are obvious lies in new york
times you know now i think it was today
or yesterday he had a story about all
the statements he's made about the wall
that are just distinctly
untrue and
all presidents
lie
everybody in government lies at some
point or another but there always was a
sort of
you know how far can you push the line
and spin
is often how you present
your case or your set of facts
in the most positive way often ignoring
other facts but trump has just made
lying
his stock in trade and again it feels
hyperbolic to say this but i think at
some point we've got to talk about it
and i know from republicans who work on
the hill i know what the republicans
particularly senators say about trump
they call him the same name that rex
tillerson called him they say that they
can't really function with him
and
we're kind of
living in partial denial
by the fact that a lot of the folks out
there won't say that publicly they wring
their hands and then they turn away when
we have a president who really
in some ways is is a disgusting human
being
if you look at what he said you know on
the access hollywood tape what he said
for years his misogynistic comments
about women comments that even paul ryan
said were racist
and yet again you know the racist
birther crusade he ran against barack
obama
and we just keep you know as a society
you know
not i think confronting the full nature
of this man
um
you know mattis's resignation letter you
know it doesn't take a lot to read
between the lines to say he has no
respect
for donald trump you know
if you read one or two of the scenes
in bob woodward's book
fear
it it seems as if the president can't
think
and again i keep coming back to this it
sounds hyperbolic but he's presented
with information
and he doesn't sit down he doesn't look
at it he doesn't absorb it he doesn't
consider it he just shoves it aside
and he will say you know the world trade
organization i think is the example that
woodward used he was they vote against
us every time every time
and they present him with the the data
saying that 87 of the time the wto the
world trade organization supports the
american position
and he can't absorb that he just shoves
it aside
so this is so i think it's rather
dangerous
i think there is a bit of a crisis here
that is hard for us to collectively
engage with and if you try to deal with
it
you fall into a partisan camp because of
this profound tribalism that donald
trump
has you know he didn't create
and he's not
the cause he's the symptom but that he
stokes
and tries to use to his
advantage
uh whether it's with the the the the
shutdown now or or anything else
and i haven't even got into the subject
of the book i wrote with mike isikoff
about you know the russian intervention
in the election
and donald trump's um basically aiding
and abetting it and refusing to come to
terms with that so i think we're in a
pretty
dark place at the moment
i think most americans are not there
most americans did not vote for donald
trump most americans voted in a way
against him in the midterms
but i do think having a a person of this
psychological profile
in the white house with all that power
is quite
dangerous and risky
and we see now
that you know
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
maybe millions of americans are being
adversely affected by the shutdown
they're not getting their paychecks some
people who have paycheck to paycheck
and he simply doesn't seem to care
he simply you know he's willing to use
them as hostages to get a wall
and breaking his biggest campaign
promise mexico was going to pay for the
wall
well now he says unless taxpayers pay
for the wall he will not you know uh
he'll have no concern for the these
hundreds of thousands of americans who
are who are who are affected by the
shutdown
yeah that's mean
that's wrong
and um
i don't i don't know exactly how we how
how they work out this small problem
compared to the big problem and how we
as a country move forward and get away
from
trump style politics
which is indeed name calling demagoguery
exploiting fear
and exploiting divisions
um
i wrote a book about obama and we'll
probably talk about it sometime in the
next three hours but one thing that did
impress me about him
that i think about a lot and i didn't
always agree with everything he did but
and i had i was lucky he had the
opportunity to talk to him a few times
while he was president
and i know his critics are not going to
believe me when i say this
they really won't but i can tell you
that he really
believed
that he had to be president for all
americans including those who did not
vote for him
and
that is not what we have in the white
house now
and we also have a white house that by
all accounts is not really functioning
it's not fully staffed it doesn't
develop policy
you know trump doesn't seem to have the
attention span
to um to focus on things
and
the way we've been lucky
that there's been no major economic
crisis there's been no
gigantic foreign policy crisis in the
last two years because i don't think we
have a functioning
president right now well you talked
about donald trump as a symptom rather
than the cause is the political
polarization
that we're currently in
is that inevitable
is that the new norm well that's a
really good question um
it's it's certainly the reality and it's
certainly i think you know
you can you can chart
chart it back as far as you want to go
you know the nixon campaign had the
southern strategy which was basically to
get
white voters who resented
changes in civil rights laws or or
measures of integration like busing to
not vote democrats to vote for
republicans and so there was a real
effort there to sort of encourage
you know or exploit this feeling of of
racial resentment that might have been
racism in some instances and you had you
know
george h.w bush you know was just lauded
when when he passed away recently and my
condolences do go to the family but his
campaign also played you know used that
to an extent and then you had the tea
party come up which was i think a very
divisive mechanism and i mean i would go
to rallies at tea party rallies where
they would have you know pictures of
obama and caricature that you had to say
was were racist and these were people
also many of them not all of them but
many of them who you know got into the
birther conspiracy which donald trump
championed which said that
they said that barack obama was not born
in america
and there was no basis for that i think
that was a racist
you know manifestation of some degree of
racism
and so there are things that are there
and the tea party came in
with i think a lot of animus
and divisiveness
and
the republican leadership
particularly john boehner the republican
leadership in congress
saw this as a way to to mobilize people
who would vote for republicans
and they ended up it ended up being a
tiger that they
couldn't fully ride on their own and
they got into a position where if they
were not confrontational on obama and
everything else
that the tea party and talk radio which
i think is another big piece of this
um
conservative talk radio would attack
them
so there a lot of this was in motion
before donald trump came along
and i do believe it's you know
people have different theories about how
countries and nations move develop
change
and is it
because of decisions made at the top
is because of what's happening at the
grassroots with the body politic
and it's obviously a bit of both
right
so the right leadership
can take
concerns of american citizens
and direct them in productive ways
or they can
inflame them
you know americans are right to be
concerned about crime
and about
chaos and
and disorder and and about border
security they're right to care about
that stuff
but if you're out there saying
there's this caravan full of terrorists
coming here and pretty soon they'll be
raping your loved ones
that
is wrong and but that does create
particularly with the media we have now
this sort of
echo chamber chamber a cycle
so instead of having responsible
leadership say saying you're right to
care about this and we're working on
solutions we're trying to work with the
other side and figure out what we can do
we're trying to work with mexican
authorities
and
send us your good ideas
you have them exaggerating the threat so
people become more
um
agitated and more fearful
and
that
is a hard cycle to break
and
it's hard to talk about this as well
without coming across as too partisan
but if you look at republican
polling polling of republicans
a lot of them still believe obama
was not born in america or that he was a
secret muslim or a socialist
42 percent of republicans recently said
that they would support donald trump if
he shut down newspapers that reported
information inaccurately
you know a lot of republicans still you
know believe the the exaggerated threat
from the border and other things
and so
there seems to me to be a bit of a fever
on the conservative republican side
and if you talk to republican
legislators a lot of them will admit to
that they won't talk about it publicly
because it's their base
and you see some conservative
media
commentators like people who used to
work at the weekly standard which closed
which have sort of raised this issue too
and
no one's really been able to quite
stop it yet
and
there may be a reckoning for the
republican party itself or but a larger
reckoning for the country because if we
can't
get past this point
it's going to be very hard to deal with
these profound issues we have whether
it's climate change
economic inequality in a growing global
economy
and you know we still we see today
um a fair amount of racial divisiveness
that needs to be dealt with particularly
as our country becomes
more diverse
um so we're really losing time
by not being able to have productive
conversations about this
and being involved in in a politics
where
you know
where anger
and fear
are
are are the double fuels
that are being used well david corn is a
political journalist and author here in
this town is it
hard
not to report on donald trump oh yeah i
mean i i mean you know my twitter feed
people say oh stop reporting on his
tweets you know why you cover everything
he says
he is the president
he does have control of our nuclear
arsenal which makes him one of the most
powerful people in all time
in all time we see what he you know what
he's able to do
with shutting down the government and
denying paychecks and even raises to
hundreds of thousands of american
citizens
so there is a lot of power we we see him
you know not
dealing with climate change in fact
going in the opposite direction and
easing regulations on industries that
contribute to um
to global warming so
i mean i i he does deserve
around-the-clock coverage
same but the coverage has to be
you know in in a way that informs
citizens
and consumers of the news and so that
they can make the right judgments about
what they do politically whether it's in
a presidential election a local election
whether they
organize themselves
on a local issue or national issue
so i mean he
he deserves i mean i'll give him this he
deserves the you know the amount of
coverage he gets i do think that the
media
collectively
made some errors when he during the
campaign
and just gave him lots of air time to
say whatever he wanted to say because he
was an entertaining carnival barker and
was good for copy and good for ratings
um and
you know i've long thought about why
why not so much why politicians lie but
what happens when they lie
and they lie
because it gives them an advantage
that's why anybody lies you you don't
tell that
when you don't tell the truth you tell
the truth when it helps you
get what you want whether it's you know
you know getting out of the house or
getting elected whatever you you know
you that's when you
tell the truth telling the truth helps
you you'll do that but you don't tell
the truth you lie you say things falsely
to gain an advantage
and
i've long thought that you know that
that
mainstream media which i don't use as a
pejorative term
i mean i have a lot of friends in the
mainstream media and i you know often
they do great work but but the culture
of it that we just report what someone
says
and then we may report the other side
you know gives an advantage to the liar
because they get the first take
if they if you know if donald trump says
you know 5 000 people are streaming
across the border now and they're about
to kill you and then five paragraphs
later you say well you know such and
such an expert says that's not going to
happen
you're still giving him the bully pulpit
and usually the headline the lead that's
the first thing people hear
and there's a lot of
interesting science in recent years
about how we our brains work and how we
hear things
and if you hear that first and it's
alarming that leaves a big impression
impression is what counts
more than information
so the president saying there's a
national threat
wow
that registers because we assume that
presidents say that when there is a
national threat and then if later on
on the the next day's story a low in the
piece or later in the show you bring on
three experts who say well it's not
really a threat but then a person says
oh it is a threat
you know the president or whoever is
acting in that way
has won
he's gotten that impression out there
and i've always wondered
why
the statement
is more newsy
than the fact that the president said
something false
so
i go back to this example and i think
it's i think i used it in one of the
books
but the day before
the invasion of iraq in march of 2003
uh there was a
story in the washington post
by dana milbank and walter pincus
and the headline was something like
experts say
president's reasons for war
are wrong don't exist or false or
undermined
and it was a it basically went through
all the reasons
that you know all the you know
all the reasons that bush and cheney had
put out there for invading iraq
saddam had a connection with al-qaeda
there were chemical weapons there was a
nuclear program you know ballistic
missiles rocket tubes and said that each
and every one of these
you know intelligence experts in the
government and outside the government
said there was reason that not to
believe that it was not proven
now that story appeared on something
like page a19
and i've always
i've asked this question now what is it
16 years 16 years
under what definition of news
is it not front page news
that the president
is bringing the nation to war
on the basis of of of statements that
that experts say are not true
i mean that to me
should have been
banned a
headline but it wasn't
colin powell's speech a month earlier
you know the washington post in this
instance they did a similar thing the
front page colin powell makes case for
invasion
that's the impression people get people
like colin powell right he was not
considered one of the
mad men of the bush cheney years oh so
colin powell was making a case for war
and then on the inside they had a double
spread where they broke down his
argument like he said chemical weapons
biological weapons nuclear program and
they had a story on each
and each story contained people saying
it's the same thing that the the case
wasn't proven that when they said this
they were exaggerating or this was
undermined or the inspectors had dealt
with this
and so yes
the washington post can say well we gave
you all the information
but the big impression they gave
and the impression that was given across
the media was that colin powell had made
a case for war
and two books that david corn has
written about the bush administration
the lies of george w bush and hubris the
inside story of spin scandal and the
selling of the iraq war you referred to
yourself as a progressive earlier on
are you up front about that in your
books
well do your books reflect that point of
view
well
most of the books are reported books
hubris i did with michael isakoff who at
the time was at newsweek
and
russian roulette which we put out a few
months ago he's now at yahoo news
um and he would call and would not
consider himself a producer i wouldn't
call that but my career is i've worked
at the nation magazine and i'm now
washington bureau chief of mother jones
which both call themselves progressive
publications
you know my you know
i'm kind of a hybrid
i will write pieces that have analysis
to it
and
and and go on msnbc as a msnbc
analyst and you know talk about things
and and know that i you know people know
by this point where where i'm coming
from but but my books are re reporting
endeavors
you know that you know if you read
russian roulette
uh there's not a lot of
you know criticism along the way
of donald trump we
report
what donald trump has done we report
things that people have not heard of
before we report on the on the obama
administration's reaction to the russian
intervention in the election too which i
think you know one can read as being in
some ways critical of them
and there's not a lot of
you know
conclusion
like analysis it's just straight
reporting and so i do that i love to do
that i love to do investigative
reporting at the same and i've done that
mainly for the nation magazine and
mother jones over the years
um
but i don't hide the fact
that you know i would if people wanted
to label me politically when they see me
on tv
um you know talking and sometimes
arguing
that i'm doing it from a progressive
bend
and in 2015 you wrote in the nation
despite all the profound changes in the
media landscape during the past several
decades the bottom line remains the same
the digging's the thing in washington
with or without a mainstream media
recognized scandal
there is always somewhere to dig
i think that's a you know that's been my
model and that story which i wrote for
the nation's 150th or whatever
anniversary issue was about
coming to washington in the late 80s and
the first story i recovered was the iran
contra scandal and i saw that there was
a lot of ding i mean i you know i kind
of believe that truth wins the day
and that truth
leads you know to better politics and
better political decision-making so
my goal is to
present the public
with truth that comes from
investigations
and i am convinced that will lead to
you know policy making and
um decisions
that i believe are best for the country
and from mother jones david cornwright
when i arrived in washington at the
start of 1987 the great journalist i f
stone who decades earlier had been my
predecessor as washington correspondent
for the nation
offered me a valuable piece of advice
stay to the end of any congressional
hearing you attend and read everything
yeah which which was which is hard i
mean
what what izzy stone was great at doing
and he worked for the nation he worked
for the new york post he had his own
newsletter he was in some ways the first
blogger he created his own independent
newsletter in the in the 60s that he i
guess mimeographed and then mailed out
individually to subscribers um he was
great at finding documents and finding
things that other people had had ignored
and
i'll say this i think in a lot of ways
the big media organizations do great
work
do great jobs
but they don't always see everything and
they also they're hindered by what i
call
not a a you know a liberal or
conservative bias or even a corporate
bias but by an official bias
they have to spend time covering the
official agenda of washington
and that you know you know that often
you know takes up space and time and
resources but it gives an opening to
journalists like myself and my
colleagues at mother jones i have 19
people who i work with in the washington
dc bureau alone
to look at places and find stories that
other people are not
looking at or not doing and even
sometimes on
on issues that are indeed already in the
news
i mean there is a lot to cover
and they're often and many stories that
there often is
and i don't mean this in this in the
pejorative way a bit of a herd mentality
there's like the obvious story
the obvious you know part of the story
that people all kind of you know get
drawn to
and
that leaves a lot of other material
uncovered
uh undercovered or not covered or
ignored and so
i've always i've always believed that
you know like izzy that you can always
find things and
and and
it's so you know in some ways it's a
little bit tougher now
because i think
um he was talking you know his
experiences were in the 50s 60s and 70s
um i think we have more media now and we
have more independent media we have more
um
people who
are or we're bloggers who are digging if
we have more independent citizen type
journalists
um
so there is more
media overall
there's more
and the challenge now becomes
when you find something how to get cut
through the clutter
and gain eyeballs as they say or gain
attention
for
good stories good solid stories that may
not be
the things
that are on the
hamster wheel that
most of us are on day in day out
so what do you read every day what how
do you start oh that's a you know a few
years ago
the atlantic magazine had a feature
where they basically asked people how do
you start your day what do you read what
do you look at
and um i i contributed to that
and i don't know that was five five
years ago
you know maybe or so and i think things
have changed a lot since then i mean i i
said i get up you know i look at my
check my email
i look at twitter you know not even i
think twitter was not one of the first
few things i looked at email to see if
any story was breaking um and then i
would you know
glance at um
the near the the hard copy of the new
york times and the washington post which
i
had delivered on
dead trees had i had yeah
past tense and now you know you know i i
get the post hard carpe each day
but i get the times only digitally
i was just getting too many newspapers
in the house
and um
but now i find and i feel you know this
is probably true for most people
that everything is has become buffet
style
a lot of it is driven at least for me by
twitter i understand from many americans
it's facebook
um so i will you know spend more time
looking at twitter to see what people
are identifying as
news of the day or things to pay
attention to
um
and then internally at mother jones we
have something called slack which a lot
of businesses use it's a it's an
internal
communication it's almost like an
internal twitter so if you you know and
you have different groups we have like a
politics chat we have a media chat we
have then we have like you know where
are you are you who are you are you
coming in late chat those type of things
and you can also do individual it's a
messaging
um
application
and
so
we have
you know
dozens of people
who are who are
looking at things across the internal
reading patterns and when they find
something that they think is you know is
notable that others should know
they put it in our slack chat
so i feel like
i've become much more
the product or the victim
of the hive mindification of the media
in that you kind of like you you decide
who you're paying attention to and then
as they
point you in different directions you
you follow that i still try
every day
to glance at the post hard copy before i
leave the house
don't always get to that
and i do then try
at some point of the day to sort of go
online and and look at
you know
home pages whether it's
times or the lawsuit journal huffington
post
um you know
buzzfeed daily beast but i do find that
a lot of the things that um that that
would have be of interest to me i've
already gotten some
notice of
and i think this is in a lot of ways a
bad thing
i think this is a bad way for us to live
collectively
there was something
quite wonderful in those quaint days
of reading a newspaper
all watching news on tv
on network news or local news
that you had to sit through or you had
to turn through things that you
otherwise wouldn't see
i still find that if i ever like you
know if i pick up the science section of
the new york times and just start
flipping through it
oh here's something i care
i'm interested in but hasn't reached me
one way or the other
and you know watching local news
waiting for the weather report
waiting for the sports
but you're still seeing what the local
city council did or your mayor did a
governor did
that i think that was great it was a
little bit of force feeding
and you know going through a newspaper
and then oh here's a story
about myanmar that i that i that that i
that just pulls me in
because i managed to look at the
headline in the in the lead we don't do
that anymore
i don't i mean at least i don't do much
i don't do as much of that as i would
like and i think collectively we do a
lot less of that and that's a bad thing
you know people talk about only getting
you know that too many americans only
get the media they want it reinforces
their their political views you know you
know liberals are watching uh msnbc
conservatives are watching fox
and they feel like you know you know to
liberals fox feels like a completely
different planet um but i do think
besides the political ramifications
it you know we
we're not as you know we can be not as
broad
as of human beings as we should be
if we only if it's so easy to get only
the information we want all you care
about is sports
and you can go to all the sports sites
and even the sports pages of your local
newspaper and just focus on sports
as opposed to having the you know
years gone by buy a newspaper
and even if you just flip through it to
get to the sports
you still supported the paper by buying
it and you might have run across
something else
and that doesn't happen anymore
so david corn let's get to books what's
the difference between
writing a book
and doing your daily business
oh my god um maybe it's the difference
between
clipping your nails and getting surgery
i mean
books are hard
i think they're supposed to be hard if
you do them right
and
the books that i've i've done
in general i guess the last four books
for three or four books they've all been
about something in the news and i've all
done them on a very very quick pace
which is
some ways frightening
in a way every time i've taken on one of
these i've worried at the beginning
whether i could do it and two of these
include you know my colleague michael
isikoff
and
you know it's we we've we've done two of
these books at a break
breakneck pace
reporting
editing
writing
all simultaneously to do a book in
basically a year
and to do a book that we're that we're
proud of that we believe
um will advance a story that's already
in the news but also uh add to it with
scoops and
and historical context um it's um
it's it's a tremendous amount of work
and it's juggling a tremendous amount of
information i mean if you take a book
that's 300 pages long
and you know a book of this nature of
these uh nature like this
how many facts are there on each page
five to ten facts on each page
okay uh
that's
a lot of facts to get
right
and to worry about and so if you have 10
facts and 300 pages that's 3 000 facts
if you get
you know
30 wrong in a book what is that one
percent
you're still getting 99 right but but
any one of those 30 facts could like
destroy your book
if it's if it's wrong in a certain way
so there's you know
there's a little bit of a of a risky
nature to you know in all journalism to
doing things quickly
while trying to go deep
and be substantial
and
you also
it also you know
the pain so to speak is drawn out over
you know
a whole year you know do i've done
articles that um
take a lot of work
and that may be sensitive or that they
worry about or they you know
um engage even some risk
but those
come and go you know they you know they
usually take less time
and you get it up there and then you
move on to the next one
and so
i don't feel like any particular article
i've done is a
is akin to being a child of mine but
books you know
not to insult my two daughters but books
feel a little bit like you're like like
like a child like something that you you
know you gave birth to
and they're going to be out there and
in hard copy on bookshelves for you know
hopefully forever
and
the stakes are just higher for books
well two of your books hubris and
russian roulette co-written with michael
isikoff
my guess is it's probably harder to
co-write a book
that's a great question and it wasn't i
made a statement so i should have asked
i have a question
like jeopardy put it in question form um
i mean i'll people ask that um
and um
and people who know me and mike
particularly asked that question you
know we both have very strong views uh
of of how we tend to see things and i
think you know uh without going too much
into our own personal psychologies
the um
the safe answer
is basically when you write a book with
of this sort with with another reporter
the first half
goes faster like the reporting the
reporting half because we divvy up okay
you're going to talk to these people i'm
going to talk to those people you're
going to focus on that those episodes
i'm going to focus on these episodes so
we really can cover
twice the ground
um that one reporter could could do so
um
the
writing in editing goes probably twice
as long as it would take either one of
us to do on our own
uh because
you know usually you know we you know
one of us would draft a section
chapter an episode whatever
and then we pass it back and forth
sometimes
once or twice sometimes a lot more
with mormon you know with changes and
suggestions
and um
occasionally and you know on on on
russian roulette
i think we came to uh
um
to a deadlock on maybe three
things not a lot on how we were going to
describe this episode it's that person
or whatever or he wanted to emphasize
this i thought we should emphasize that
and um which i think in the grand scheme
of things
is not a lot
and we
brought in our editor as an arbitrator
uh to figure it out and we figured out
is it carol ross no she's your agent
yeah gail ross is our agent now this is
sean desmond
at 12 of a division of hachette and i
really have to tip my hat to sean for
always keeping his cool
about this when he was very you know
from his perspective the book had to get
done by a certain time so it could be
published at a certain time and
that's in part of you know having a
short deadline i think it helps
um a partnership because we were both
under the same
deadline both under the gun
and so we realized we you know whatever
you have to resolve it
you know you have to resolve it what was
the movie i think it was called what's
it called the
sound like the fugitives there's a movie
in the 60s with um tony curtis
and sydney partier i believe and they
were on a
on a on a
prison the chain gang and they escaped
together but
they're chained together
one's a white southern bigot the other
is a black man and so
they have to figure out
how to survive together you know while
chained together if they're going to
escape and not you know be brought back
and you you know in this type of project
you're like that we had to figure things
out
i know people who've been in
uh
partnerships working on books
and had a much longer
timeline to finish
and had a lot more problems
they had more time to argue and they had
time to say well we're not going to
resolve this and things would just
linger and fester we basically you know
if there was a wound cut it off and move
on we had to keep going keep going
was there evidence did you find evidence
of collusion
good question
it depends
on the meaning of collusion
i mean donald trump
has staked so much on this no collusion
no collusion no collusion
well he seems to think that collusion
only comes if he had a phone call with
putin and told putin where russian
hackers should attack the dnc computers
and when to release the material
well there's no evidence of that and
there probably wouldn't be because it
wouldn't necessarily have to be like
that
what what i think is that there
there is
certainly a collaboration
and as we put it in the book on the last
page
and this is something that mike and i
obviously had to agree on was that trump
aided and abetted
the russian attack it's not interference
meddling it's an attack on the u.s
election
and there are a couple of easy ways to
to show that
one is the infamous infamous
june tower meeting
june 2016. when don jr
paul manafort and jared kushner
top three guys in the trump campaign
met with a russian emissary
who they were told
was bringing them dirt
on hillary clinton now they say that the
information she offered was of no use to
them and that was the end of it
but the email that came in to don jr
describing the emissary what this was
all about
said
this is part of a kremlin plan
to help trump
so they're being notified that there's a
secret kermit plan
to help donald trump and what do they
say to that
we're in we love i mean literally i love
it was what donald trump emailed back to
the intermediary
so they at that point in time they are
sending a signal to the russians that if
you're doing anything to help us
that's fine with us we like that
five days
i think five days after that meeting was
the first
public account that the russians had had
had attacked and penetrated the
democratic national committee
the trump campaign response to that
was
this is obviously a hoax that the
democrats are making up
because they have such a lousy candidate
think about it five days earlier they
had a meeting with the russian who they
were told was part of a secret kremlin
campaign
and so
they of anybody else in the world have
now been given
an indication that the russians want to
mess in the election
and they come out and they say this is a
hoax
well that's a lie
because it wasn't
and why would they say that how did they
know it was a hoax they didn't know that
they had no basis for saying that
so the russians are attacking
and the trump campaign comes out and
said and when they're caught says it's
not happening so that's giving them
cover right then and there
okay
at the convention the democratic
convention that's when they released the
russians released released 22 000 of the
dnc emails and documents that they had
stolen
broken the law to steal
uh robbie mook
the
uh campaign chairman of manager for
hillary clinton goes on tv and says the
russians are doing this they're
attacking our campaign
they bring you know they and they want
to help trump
he says most things
that same day donald trump jr paul
manafort who were in that very meeting
they come out and they say how dare
robbie mook say this
you know they're just making this up
they're taking this into the gutter
blaming this on the russians
and manafort even says later i have
nothing to do with russia himself
and he says trump had nothing to do with
russia
now all that is a lie
again they know
that russia is doing something
they're denying it's happening
paul manafort
had
owed 18 million or so to a russian
oligarch close to putin who he was
trying to communicate with while running
the campaign
and donald trump
himself
was working with the russians to build a
tower
in moscow at least until june of 2016
but through the fall of 2015 in the
winter of 2016 while he's a candidate
for president
he is working to build a tower in moscow
and michael cohen
that is happening
calls putin's office to ask for help
so
trump then goes on after the convention
and calls on the russians to hack
hillary you know famously go find those
emails please hacker
then in october excuse me in august
he
gets an intelligence briefing he's now
the republican nominee this is standard
he's told in that briefing
that russia is behind the attacks
and probably the dissemination of
material it came from the dnc what does
he do he comes out right afterwards and
says no one knows it's russia it's a
hoax and he says the same thing
at the debates in early october the
obama administration publicly declares
russia as the culprit
he comes out again and says who knows
who knows it's like a guy 400 pound guy
in the basement it's not russia has
nothing to do with this
so think about it
his people are told russia's invol wants
to mess in the election
he himself is told directly the u.s
intelligence community is has concluded
this
and he gets out there and he echoes
he repeats
russian disinformation
because putin kept saying we have
nothing to do with this
we have nothing to do with this
so he is making it now a political issue
democrats say this
trump says it's not the russians
and politicizing this
that helps the russians
the metaphor that i that i use
personally is that it's like a guy on a
street corner in front of a bank
the bank is being robbed
he is told the bank is being robbed he
turns around
there's guys in there with masking guns
banks being robbed as people come by
they say what's happening he says
nothing nothing's happening at all it's
all fine
now whether or not he was in on the
initial
caper
he is helping them get away with a
robbery
in legal terms aiding and abetting after
the fact in some circumstances can be a
crime even
but he's doing that and in this case
he you know is the beneficiary of what's
happening
he is the beneficiary of the russian
operation
which i think you can make the argument
was
decisive in the election as well as a
dozen other decisive factors not on its
own
so
i already
believe that whatever robert mueller
will make make known to the public
anything that comes out of the senate
intelligence committee investigation
that's still underway
there's already enough to say
that donald trump acted in a way
that you could call
betrayal
he helped a foreign power get away with
an attack that was very deliberate on
our
democracy and our electoral system
and that's you know whether that you
know we want to call that colluding
colluding with the with the russian
cover-up um helping them get away with
it
and to me
that is the big fact here that has not
been fully absorbed that trump has
indeed succeeded
in creating a different standard on
which to be judged
and in fact
david corn you wrote in a mother jones
piece in a non-trumpified world
revelations of this behind-the-scenes
scheming for profit would have set off
an enormous political earthquake
after all this was the most significant
conflict of interest in modern american
campaign history
but trump has changed the rules of what
counts as a political scandal i mean
think about this
when he was running for president
and often asked to talk about putin and
russia
in which he
bizarrely often said things that were
positive about putin
and fended off criticism of putin
he was trying to do a deal in moscow
that would have brought him
hundreds of millions of dollars
according to uh robert mueller one of
the
um pleadings in the michael cohen case
so
he's not a he's not a dummy
he knows he can't have a deal like that
go through
if he's out there criticizing putin
and russia he's campaigning as the
american america first candidate
yet here he
is you know engaged in this in this in
this project in moscow that he's not
telling the public about
and in fact he's lying about his
relationship to the guy
a man named felix sater who's pulling it
together
we write about this in the book when
asked about felix sater in december of
2015 a man he had worked with for years
he said i i don't think i'd recognize
him but that very moment
sater is negotiating this deal
in russia
for donald trump and trump has already
signed a letter of intent so he's fully
aware of all this
now if any other candidate at any other
moment in time
if he had been while campaigning
secretly going to the
the the the head of a foreign power even
a rival power and saying hey can you
help me make 100 million dollars here
i think that would have been it
that in and of itself
put aside collusion put aside aiding and
abetting put aside the trump tower
meeting put aside any of that stuff
that in and of itself should be
the subject of congressional hearings
an investigation
it's a major thing but trump
throws
so much
chaff into the air
that it's sometimes hard to see things
clearly and there are so many different
scandals now
that you know that
it's it's he's i think purposefully
making this sort of dizzying pattern
you know
of saudi prince went to one of his
apartments the hotels last year
and bought nine million dollars in rooms
that he might not have even needed
that goes directly to trump's company
directly to his pocket
so that you know and you don't think
that the saudis let trump know that they
did that
i mean this is like bribery and that
only became public because a memo about
it leaked we don't know this could be
happening
every week at the trump hotel any one of
his properties
that that nine million dollar payoff
i mean richard nixon got in trouble for
taking a cloth coat
you know and getting a pet dog checkers
and gave a whole speech about it i mean
we're talking about millions of dollars
in money
that might be considered bribes and
that's just one thing right there
i mean you can talk about
zinke and pruitt and and and um
and and and wilbur ross i mean they're
all these you know nepotism how they're
giving out security clearances i mean
there are
the democrats have taken over the house
now
must really be puzzling hard about what
to focus on
tax returns deutsche bank
the president united states
has you know owes hundreds of millions
millions of dollars to a foreign bank
that's had regulatory trouble with the
justice department here for a number of
reasons including
a a
a scandal of their own which which might
have involved russian money laundering
um
so do you focus on that
you know you focus on the emoluments the
payments
and so going back to the the russian
deal
i think that under any other
administration under any other
set of
circumstances people have been
screaming holy hell and even republicans
would have
but they have made a strategic
calculation
the republican party
that they are going to tie themselves to
the mast of the uss trump
and you ride it or go down with it
welcome to book tv this is our in-depth
program every first sunday of the month
we feature one author to talk about his
or her body of work this month it's
mother jones bureau chief here in
washington d.c and best-selling author
david corn he is the author of six books
beginning with blonde ghost back in
1994. we'll learn a little bit about
that later deep background which came
out in 1999 is actually a novel we'll
talk about that the lies of george w
bush
2003 and hubris 2006 both about the bush
administration
showdown the inside story of how obama
fought back against boehner cantor and
the tea party came out in 2012 and his
most recent bestseller co-authored with
michael isikoff is russian roulette the
inside story of putin's war on america
and the election of donald trump which
we've spent a bit of time talking about
already today but we're going to put the
phone numbers up this is your chance to
talk with david corn we've spent an hour
talking now it's your turn 202 is the
area code 748 8200 if you live in the
east and central time zones 748 8201 for
those of you in the mountain and pacific
time zones now if you can't get through
on the phone line still want to make a
comment try our social media sites
facebook or twitter
book tv is our handle and we'll begin
taking those calls in just a few minutes
david corn these
situations such as the election of 2016
and and
other
scandals and things that have happened
in washington sometimes these things get
a little murky you've got christopher
steele you've got a dossier you've got
gps fusion you've got uh
hillary clinton emails you've got the
fbi you've got the dnc
are these things murky on purpose or is
it just that they grow
like topsy that's a good question maybe
life itself tends to be murky um
and there's some obviously
the political interest in making things
murkier
and to you know making things muddy on
purpose uh we talked a moment ago about
what i consider some of the
the big points
of the trump-russia scandal and his
aiding and abetting the russian attack
you know trump i think purposely tries
to make things murky
um by
saying obama wiretapped me
not true what about hillary
the dnc server
another red herring and you have people
um in congress republicans and this
troubles me greatly who are on the
intelligence committee who are supposed
to you know get to the bottom of what
happened with the russian attack on the
u.s election in 2016 and instead they're
out there
raising all sorts of you know tangential
issues about a fisa warrant you know
particular
you know whether whether the fisa
warrant which is the ability to wire
capitalist avail
of a trump former trump campaign advisor
named carter page was done properly or
not and they spent all this time on that
and make that the big issue
um
and
should it be looked at yeah i'm not
saying it shouldn't but that they make
that the focus and they also then say
things that you know there's been a lot
of lying and false statements made in
pursuit of that as a narrative it's
basically creating
competing narratives and some of them
have
involved me personally that are very
conspiratorial uh and i just know for a
fact that that they're wrong
and but that they're trying to make
things murky because
by and large
if you're on the wrong side of a scandal
if you did something wrong if you
you know aided and embedded a russian
attack in the united states
it's really hard to argue
that you
that you're right that you didn't do
something wrong so what do you do
you create distractions or you raise
other issues what about you know trump
does this all the time how come they're
not investigating hillary's email server
well they did
they did investigate it james comey gave
a whole press conference and then you
know
he investigated it again
at the end of the election and made that
and that became public perhaps
improperly
and so
but you know trump can't get out there
and he won't address the question
why did you deny it was the russians
after being told in an intelligence
briefing that the u.s
intelligence community believed it was
why did you do that instead he talks
about everything else so
a situation that is complicated that has
a lot of component piece pieces
can be easily be made
murky
on purpose and that was one reason that
mike and i wrote russian roulette
because we felt that this seemed to be a
scandal with a lot of moving pieces
going in different directions and
different players different parts of the
world
and
we wanted to sort of
basically tell the story as we know it
up to this particular point
and
i mean the book's done very well and
it's very gratifying that people have
but particularly people have read it
very seriously and embraced it and i you
know i get approached on the street when
i travel
and with people who've read the book
and literally 10 out of 10 comments i
get in those situations
are a version of now i get the big
picture
now i understand because i there was too
much going on out there it comes out in
iterative
small bites in the new york times we get
a a scoop the washington post wall
street journal maybe we at mother jones
about roger stone about the trump tower
meeting about a meeting in seychelles
about a connection to the middle east
and all this what's that all about and
it's very hard for folks to
absorb that and place it in the cosmos
of the scandal
i was talking even to a reporter
um
who covers this for one of the major
newspapers
and he said i really enjoyed reading
your book it gave me a sense of the
whole because i'm still every day and
this is the person who's gotten a fair
number of scoops so yes i do think it's
kind of difficult particularly in our
critified world
of getting
dollops of news here there whatever and
everything moving on very quickly
so um that was something that we aim we
tried to do with the book to make things
not murky and give people a foundation
so as new stories arise they know they
can basically absorb and put them into
context
before we get too far from if stone and
your journalism background
you've had several scoops in your career
47 percent around contra
et cetera
yeah well i mean that's kind of what
i've tried to do i mean to me you know
i'm happiest
when i'm breaking a news story that
others haven't gotten the getting the 47
percent tape that mit of mitt romney is
saying in during the 2012 campaign
that he believed 47 of americans
don't pay taxes don't take
responsibility for themselves and don't
want to take responsibility for
themselves and we don't i don't really
have to care about them because they're
not voting for me anyway i thought was a
a revelatory moment people got to see
what mitt romney said
said to funders when he didn't believe
he was being watched
and
you know the great thing about that
scoop in particular
was it wasn't according to sources
here was video
you everybody could watch this we put
the full video out there you know the
first
i think the first response from the
romney camp something like oh this was
taken out of context
no we gave you the context we you know
you know we put out the you know a
minute of the video before and after the
response and then the next day we put
out the whole video
so that didn't work so that was very
gratifying because that was the type of
story that you really can't challenge
uh i can't really even ignore it because
you know video is so compelling but um
i've had other stories you know
that valerie playing valerie plame in in
2003
uh
when uh when when the columnist
conservative columnist bob novak wrote a
story
noting that ambassador joe wilson who
had become a critic of the war in iraq
and who said and and challenged some of
the intelligence used to justify the war
um and created a bit of a firestorm
uh robert novrak reported that his wife
worked at the cia
as if to suggest this was part of a cia
campaign against the bush cheney white
house
and that caused a whole fuss because she
was an undercover
intelligence official
and i
was the first to write
that the leaking of her name
might be a crime
there was something called the
intelligence identities protection act
which made it illegal
for
people in the u.s government
to identify undercover
intelligence officers
so
possibly whoever told novak not that he
broke the law but whoever told novak
they were government officials might
have violated the law
and that
led to
a lot of discussion that eventually led
to
the appointment of a special counsel
that
investigated this
a guy who nearly
indicted karov as we tell michael mike
isabella and i tell him the book hubris
but who did indict and convict scooter
libby
dick cheney's white house chief of staff
and
we spoke a little bit about mitt romney
and of course he's back now with senator
romney but in russian roulette you write
that steele reported that
putin and the kremlin were not happy
about the idea that mitt romney was
being considered for secretary of state
they asked trump to find someone who was
more friendly to russia after which rex
tillerson was picked
you know the steele does the steele
dossier they call it the dossier i've
never liked that term
it's a collection of memos that he sent
intermittently
after he was hired by fusion gps
in june of 2016.
so i mean to me a dossier is something
that's
collected and thought about and vetted
these are like here's what i'm hearing
here's a memo
one source says this one source says
that um i you know the first memo i
thought was the mo and i i think i was
the first reporter to report on these
was to be the most chilling when it said
that the you know russians had a
years-long campaign to co-opt and
cultivate trump and then there are
details there about you know you know
salacious
acts
that may or may not have been committed
and then throughout the rest of the
memos a lot of details about what's you
know purported details or what's going
on in the kremlin in terms of the attack
on the election and what you are citing
is one of the last memos that still sent
now all these are have not been
fact-checked or confirmed by steel or by
anybody else it's sort of like this is
what sources are telling me um and
they're private i mean i as a journalist
i kind of get this i have people who
tell me all sorts of things what goes on
in the trump white house or going on in
congress or anyplace else
and sometimes i will send a note to my
fellow reporters or to my fellow editors
say i'm hearing this i'm hearing that
you know but it's not something i put up
online it's not something i tweet about
because i haven't you know proven it
so here we have an unproven report
private report from steele
that if true would be explosive
and amazing if this was true we do know
that trump
talked to romney about the secretary of
state job my own personal view is that
trump was
you know was playing him wanted to get
you know romney who had been very
critical of trump wanted to get him
basically to kiss the ring and once he
did that i don't need you we do know he
ended up with rex tillerson who had
a very very friendly relationship with
putin poonah didn't give him an award
because x mo
exin mobile had done a lot of work
that he when he headed with russia
so
you know this is exactly the type of
thing that you'd want
the house
or the senate intelligence committee to
investigate and let us the public know
if there's any truth to this
let's take some calls david corn is our
guest in marjorie's in pratt west
virginia hi marjorie you're on book tv
on c-span 2.
hi thank you for taking my call
david i have a topic going to ask you
about but first i want to tell you where
i live we're sort of infamous for having
jailed mother jones back
when she was working with unions
i'm from a coal mining union family
thought you might find that interesting
but here's my question i'd like your
observations about
as you know republicans are always
wanting to put social security in the
stock market and cut medicare and
medicaid as they cite the need to fix
our debt problems there's a website i'm
wondering if you're familiar with called
good jobs first
that tells us the amounts of money
congress takes from our taxes and gives
by the billions even trillions from
taxpayer-funded subsidies every year to
wall street banks including foreign
banks like deutsche bank that you just
mentioned
we taxpayers give corporations like oil
companies
4.4 billion dollars every year all the
while paul ryan's budgets called for
taking 4 billion every year out of food
stamps the oil industry's quarterly
profits were 18 billion why should food
stamp money social security medicare
medicaid be on the chopping block every
time republicans get in power
pharmaceutical companies and as i've
said these other kinds of all right
marjorie i think we got the point uh
marjorie who was mother jones
oh my goodness she was a famous
coal mining lady that she fought with
our coal miners we
we
live near a place called paint creek
where there was a train that went up and
down the tracks that shot
coal mining families that lived in tents
along the railroad tracks but mother
jones was just famous for helping the
unions
get their union rights um thank you
ma'am
she was a long time union organizer
working as we heard with coal miners
there but also in other
high-profile
you know
were basically wars you could call them
for labor labor rights and union rights
when often you know as she mentioned you
know there was violence um with
pinkerton guards being sent in by
companies coal mining companies silver
mining companies and other companies to
break up the union and to
attack if sometimes not even kill people
who were demanding
labor rights so
she the magazine mother jones was
started in the 70s and was named after
her because she called herself a hell
raiser and that's what the founders of
the magazine wanted to do muckraking
hellraising
to her to her question i mean that's a
great question because it gets to you
know the heart of of our politics and i
wish it's the type of thing that we
could be discussing
on a daily basis you know we're talking
fundamentally about values when we get
together and you know in
legislators legislatures across the
state and in congress
and talk about tax codes and who gets
what tax cut rates and who gets what tax
subsidies and who can write off this
write that off we're talking about
values
we're talking about money and at the
same time and i think she's you know she
points out that paul ryan who was
considered you know and often hailed as
a great policy wonk here in washington
who i mean who just left as house
speaker often put forward budgets that
really really crunched and put pressure
on
social security medicare medicaid
at the same time while supporting tax
cuts like we saw
with the
trump tax cuts that really give back a
lot of money to the to the wealthy at a
time
when they're not hurting and there's no
evidence that doing so
you know fuels economic growth and in
fact you know they always say these tax
cuts pay for themselves because they get
spent there's more economic activity but
tax revenues are down
after those tax cuts and the deficit
which paul ryan
and other budget hawks always claim to
care about
has gone up
tremendously
but without you know because we're
paying for a wall or without because
we're
a war i should say we're not you know
we're not paying money for war we're not
coming out of an economic crisis like
obama inherited and the deficit went up
a little bit because he spent money on
stimulus to get people working again uh
or he spent money on the you know the uh
the auto bailout that worked a lot
so there are reasons when deficit
spending is is can be a positive
we all you know if you buy a house if
you take out a loan to send a kid to
college you're taking on debt for
good reason
um but
we see now you know with
with conservative budget hawks that
really they don't care about the deficit
of the national debt they just went
ahead and voted for these tax cuts
without offsetting them and then they
come back and say now we have to cut
more further out of social spending
programs
so that's a fundamental fight
that we've been having in this country
for decades there's a fundamental fight
of the budget battles
uh during obama's years which i write
about in the book showdown and it
continues today and i think
unfortunately we get we get trump is
very good at distracting
and
it's hard to sort of actually focus on
that now that the democrats have
controlled the house i expect these
these value-oriented
budget fights will get more attention
and the wall is a little bit a part of
that here's trump who promised that he
could build the wall without taxing the
american public
mexico would pay for it
and
what is he doing he's just asking for
five billion dollars more in deficit
spending to build the wall and he claims
the money comes from
a better trade deal with mexico but we
don't see that money coming in and who
gets the benefits of that does that
money go to the u.s treasury maybe it
will go to
corporations you know which may benefit
but not it doesn't necessarily flow
right into the u.s treasury so it's kind
of
we're kind of like at the end of
ideology in a way like there's no
at least i would say the republicans
by embracing trump have have thrown away
their ideology
which was
you know smaller government
you know tax breaks but you know care
about the deficit and debt spending
and
they've
they they've thrown away that they've
thrown away their sometimes their
hawkish foreign policy
you know just by letting trump do
whatever he wants to do
and that is you know i don't know how
the you know what the reason is for the
republican party anymore other than to
support trump
kathy's in leavenworth washington and
kathy you're on with author and
journalist david corn
okay let me why don't i get to the core
of the problem we have in this country
and in this world really
is that um
well first of all the founding fathers
didn't want another king george running
rampant
and in article one section nine line
eight the emoluments clause it begins
with and i quote
no title of nobility shall be granted by
the united states
no title of nobility
and yet
what is it okay first of all i am a
progressive
i've had it with both democrat and
republican parties you kiss up to what
senators
congressmen
you're so surprised
when they they take money
it goes on and no person holding any
office of profit or trust under them
shall without the consent of the
congress except of any present emolument
officer title of any kind whatever from
any king prince or foreign state
and now i have to sit here in front of
my tv and listen to people spin about
gee
what do you think
maybe this why doesn't he do that you
know what
we should prosecute
those that commit crimes their crimes
get people killed that iraq war oh yeah
we're helping them and then we wonder
why we have terrorists over here
after we kill what about a million
people
and oh we're not going to trust iran
after that coup in 53
all that we got put you know and does
that ever get in our textbooks no
all right cathy thank you david corn
well there's a lot to unpack in that but
i i i appreciate and respect her
frustration
because i do think
um there's a lot of anger out there
that's justified when they look at
washington and they don't see washington
addressing you know key issues and they
do see
politicians on both sides of the aisle
democrat and republicans taking money
from corporate interests
and you know
people in washington would have you
believe that washington is the only
place in the entire world that if
someone gives you money you don't feel
obligated to them
doesn't affect me whatsoever
and you know that it is the our campaign
finance system
is the biggest denial of human nature
that i can think of
uh
in my in my in my short time on the
world here uh it is you know and so you
know
i think everybody who you know who
engages in that system puts himself
at
risk of being challenged by a caller
like this how do we know where your true
loyalties lie and are they to the people
who vote for you in the american public
and the public interest are they to
people who basically give you money so
you can keep your job
and that's you know it's a problem for
the democrats it's a problem for
republicans now democrats by and large
support doing something about this not
all of them doing what they support
doesn't always go far enough but mitch
mcconnell one of his goals in life has
been to prevent
any real campaign finance reform so i
think that is a fundamental issue that
we
have to come to terms with and her
mentioning the emoluments clause
you know
fits into that because that clause
basically says that the president cannot
take gifts from foreign
officials or entities
now that's trump has been doing this
throughout the presidency
your foreign states foreign governments
as i noted earlier in the show are
buying up blocks of rooms in his hotels
and properties
and he owns the company he owns trump
organization thought he prints spends
nine million dollars on a property in
new york in buying rooms that he doesn't
even stay in that money is directly a
part of trump's income stream and he has
not taken the steps necessary
to separate himself from that and make
that not a problem
there's also a problem with conflicts of
interest with of ivanka and
with jared as well it's separate matter
and there is actually now a lawsuit
that's been moving ahead and it's gone
pretty far
that uh the group called crew has has
filed on against trump on monuments and
you know that again you know we talked
about all the different scandals out
there and how there are so many that
it's hard to focus on any but uh if
jimmy carter if jimmy carter's peanut
farm
had you know taken in nine million
dollars from a saudi prince to buy a
plot of land
you can bet that congress would have
been all over that
karen
emails in
how much new material will be in the
april paperback edition of russian
roulette
and how does she know that there's a
april edition it's not there's nothing
uh set in stone about when the paperback
edition will come out so uh mike and i
have not really uh finished
uh writing what will be new in the
in the in the in the paperback edition
uh so i can just say stay tuned
but we will be bringing the book you
know up to speed on what we've learned
since
uh the book came out and and will that
be in april
no not
necessarily has not been said
margaret
tweets in
what is your next topic or focus for
investigative reporting in book form oh
if you
look at the books
and the dates in which they came out the
years in which they came out 18 12
3
or 6
3. yeah you see there's a little bit of
a pattern there
so i would i would say give me some time
i mean um it it it was a great you know
it was it was as i said it was kind of
painful to write but but releasing the
book and the reaction to it was
very rewarding and gratifying and so i
would happily you know do another but
right now kind of
looking to see what the next book should
be and whether there you know should be
a particular follow-up to this or not
the story now is still
unsettled
and we don't know also when it will be
settled
and without that it's unclear to what
degree there will be
the opportunity
for a book follow-up books are very
i think they're very special items
um they're you know you know there's so
much you can get done
with news stories and with magazine
pieces and people who follow the news
get so much information about subjects
like these that they get for free or
they get from reading daily papers or
the work that i do at mother jones that
mike does at yahoo news
right so to get people to really sit
down to get off
the twitter wheel and spend time with a
book
i think you have to have something
special
well back on the twitter wheel
from this morning the president's tweet
okay this morning i don't know if you
saw this or not
how do you impeach a president who has
won perhaps the greatest election of all
time done nothing wrong no collusion
with russia it was the dems that
colluded had the most successful first
two years of any president and is the
most popular republican in party history
93
i mean
this is this is an everyday occurrence
the president tweets something that if
any other person said this you would say
they were deluded
these are delusions
done nothing wrong i mean
there are
dozens of things that deserve
investigation things that he has done
wrong and i earlier went through
that relation somewhat just some of them
in relation to the trump-russia scandal
um
and he
i mean
he you know we we have to pay notice to
tweets like these but at the same time
they just they they deserve a collective
shrug
you know he is out there saying and
tweeting things
constantly that are just not true you
know the other day every president every
living president has told me that they
wish they had built the wall
he said that
so
what happens
you know media reporters doing their job
contact every living president and they
say
never talk to him about the wall
okay
outright lies
i mean there's a pathology here
and if you talk about trump
as a nurse as a narcissist as a
pathological liar
again it sounds hyper partisan
but um and he hides behind that by you
know all critics of him are losers
mattis is a loser bad general the guy
who he praised now because he implicitly
criticized trump in his farewell letter
you know everybody who he hires is the
best everybody he fires is the worst
i mean he lives in this and he is the
grandest
um
it's
to me
i mean he that's sad
but the sad thing to me
is that that doesn't turn off
a third of the public whatever his base
is 30 to 35 percent that they accept
this
they accept him calling
people
on the other side losers they accept his
meanness they accepted him shouting or
encouraging people shout lock her up
putting us acting like we're a damn
banana republic
that we lock up our political opponents
this is a man without an ounce of grace
and and without any honesty
and
i don't know how future historians are
going to deal with this and deal with
the american public's reaction to him
and with the republican party's embrace
i mean he's right
he has
very high approval ratings amongst
republicans
but not amongst anybody else
who i think see
some of his
traits
i mean again whether it's the access
hollywood tape whether it's you know the
the the scores of misogynistic remarks
he made before even after
becoming president and racist remarks
and you know calling an american judge a
mexican and that's why he's rolling
against me
when trump university again
we forgot about that there's a there's a
scandal trump foundation there's a
scandal i mean all these things would
bring down any other politician
justifiably you run a foundation you
break the law you shouldn't be elected
president you shouldn't be elected dog
catcher
and the foundation is rotten
they spend money on his own portrait to
hang up in one of his own country clubs
again
if jimmy carter had done that if bill
clinton had done that
but um
so i don't know you know i i at some
point
i would say i'm at a loss for words but
i just ranted for a long time well let's
hear from marie in new york city hi
marie
marie you with us
hey marie i apologize reminder if you
get through on the phone lines turn down
the volume there's a little delay
and you'll hear everything through the
phone i promise
carol greensburg pennsylvania hi carol
hello
i want to know
what else you're reading that's not
political
although it may have political overtones
what are you
able to do in writing about other things
other than political because so much of
what you're doing is political but
there's a whole world of people out
there hurting
i'd just like to know a little bit more
about what you're reading and writing
other than the subjects we're talking
about today well you are a political
journalist and political author so right
but i do like to read about other things
in fact
i have found in the last two years
to
as an antidote to some of the craziness
to when i
come up with a bit of a routine that is
i try
as hard as i can i couldn't really do
this while i was writing the book but
after the book was done at 10 o'clock at
night
turn off all screens
so i you know i look at my twitter feed
i look at my email
see if anything's breaking you know
check my messages in my internal mother
jones slack chat
and but then i try to say okay
turn it off
and then i try to you know i do some
exercising but also read
and i've found that the way i can get to
sleep best is not by reading anything
about what's happening now that's
directly related to my day-to-day job
uh whether it's mother jones or writing
the book
so i've been reading a lot of history
i mean i read a great book it's sort of
a historical book
i think it's called earth and human
hands by my pal david grinspoon it's
about a a it's sort of like a history of
the planet geologically and he
is a wonderful astro uh
biologist studies planets i was won all
these awards and i was just really
thinking about big picture stuff rather
than but but also i i read ron chernow's
book on grant
which was which was fabulous and made me
think a lot about the 1850s
where things were very very divisive in
this country and in the end of the day
we failed
we failed
uh we ended up with the civil war you
know and hundreds of thousands of are
you suggesting parallels well
no i'm not saying that we're going to
end up in the same place but it's like
okay that was a very divisive time and
we could not figure out how to get out
of it collectively
without
tremendous spasm of violence um
but so but chernow's book and grant is
fabulous you know i don't understand
much i don't really say that it's better
than the hamilton book
but
grant in some ways is even more
interesting
than hamilton hamilton was kind of a
straight rise he had his sex scandal and
all that grant
was basically a bum he was living like a
hobo at one point in his life in san
francisco in a flop house and didn't
have the dollar to pay for that night's
room
and had to go to a veteran
office and ask for a buck and he becomes
this great general
and a present united states it's a great
story
and it's also
shows a tremendous amount of ugliness in
the politics before the war and more
importantly what happens in
reconstruction after the war there were
there were the racial violence in the
south from the clan i mean i kind of
knew about this but no i was
shocked
one
racial massacre after another with white
folks after the war trying to keep black
people from voting to maintain power in
the south i mean it is it is horrendous
you know the
and in some and then i'm reading now
these truths by jill lapore which is a
great history of america from
columbus to the present i'm halfway
through it but i just heard this line
last night which is that the confederacy
lost the war but won the peace
because the amount of racial violence
and the power of slave holding
you know formerly safe holding whites in
the south you know remained firm through
violence in that period of time
incredibly ugly we don't know enough
about that but then also
for i i read steve hawk i've read
stephen hawking's last book
unfortunately passed away last year uh
brief
answers to big questions
and i gotta admit i don't get all of it
i can't follow all of it but when he
talks about
time space in the universe where it came
from where it's going what that means
about whether there's a god or not what
that means about the nature of time and
can you time travel or not i get a lot
of it and i just like thinking in those
terms because you talk about perspective
when you're talking about
the size of the universe and how big you
are and where we are in comparison to
that
and then where we are you know on the
planet in comparison to that
i mean it really you know it it puts a
lot of your day-to-day problems
and and
and stark relief when you think about
that and and he's just such a stun he
was just such a stunning story of
courage
uh that he could write any of the books
uh is great and then i like to you know
read novels as well and the last one i i
read finished a couple weeks ago was
warlight by michael undatje who's one of
my favorite novelists
best known for writing the english
patient which is also a movie
but he's a marvelous writer and when you
and i
peter we're at the miami book fair a
couple like about two months ago
whenever that was
he was there
and i was lucky enough i was lucky
enough to meet him and have lunch with
him
and that was like i was like you get to
play fan boy i was i was so fanboy and i
attended the talk that he gave
and i had some real questions about the
book but they all involved spoiling it
and you know parts of it giving away
parts of the book
and it's a marvelous story about two
adolescents after the at the end of
world war ii who are more or less
abandoned by their parents
and are being watched over by
folks who
only have one one foot on the right side
of the law and how they you know
involves greyhound smuggling and and all
sorts of gambling and
and it ends with a pretty major twist
involving a very little known
act of
of war crime during world war ii uh but
anyway so i had all these questions for
him and i ran into the author's lounge
and assaulted him he goes let's have
lunch let's eat and he was delightful he
was great and
you know there's nothing like meeting
someone whose work
you really really enjoy and has meant a
lot to you and then who turns out to be
a swell person that's not always the
case
that he was
charlie rosalind heights new york thanks
for holding you're on with author and
journalist david corn
hey how you doing uh you got me with
shave cream on my face but that's okay
you know before i ask my questions i
like to make uh make a comment uh i'm an
independent progressive which means i'm
against identity politics
i think this is causing uh uh causing
us to uh identity politics is
defensiveness form into genuine the rest
of women i'm against like black
nationalism or women's lib i believe in
equality for all but i'm against these
things and i think all progressives need
to speak out against this now if you let
me get my glasses on over here can i do
that
sure
go ahead charlie
now there's two things uh that i want to
bring out uh
in the 1980s i noticed the corporate
takeover
of the democratic and the republican
parties i don't see anybody talking
about that i think that was important
because that that got rid of the
fairness doctrine uh we had something
called a fairness doctrine i was
involved with politics back in the 70s
and i remember how how more balanced
things were things were not perfect but
they were a lot more balanced
and when they got rid of that in the
late 80s to stand this doctrine it just
went off the cliffs
uh all right so we got the fairness
doctrine and and very quickly what else
did you want to ask
well the corporation of the democratic
and republican parties thank you sir
thanks for calling we'll let you go back
to shaving
david corn well first i want to give
charlie uh a recommendation
he should go see the movie vice
by adam mckay which um
i've seen and i did an interview with
adam which will be coming out this week
in mother jones which act because it
mentions the fairness doctrine
uh which if uh viewers don't know
was a a regulation basically
for
tv
stations that if you covered one side of
an issue you had to give the other side
basically equal time
um
this covered broadcast stations because
they are regulated in a way different
than what cable is now
and during the reagan years uh the
reagan administration got rid of that
and that allowed particularly radio
stations
um to have just say rush limbaugh
or you know or conservative talk around
all day long and not have
anything on the other side and did the
same with local tv stations like
sinclair which would
you know which has a lot of local
stations and is using them to promote
you know conservative political position
would would under the old rule
not be able to do that so easily so
that's what he's talking about
cable
i have this right would not be regulated
in the same way so fox could still be
fox and msnbc could still be an snbc but
that was a
that was something that conservatives
and republicans targeted in the reagan
years in order to not have in order to
have a more
powerful voice to the public
to be fair wasn't there reasoning okay
you have the big three cbs nbc and abc
they're all reporting the same thing
they're all liberal
our message isn't getting out well
that's what they said but i mean i think
you can make you know
saying that
you know calling them liberal i thought
was always a misnomer
and even i think bill crystal has
acknowledged that that was something
that they that was devised as a pr thing
to rally the conservative republican
base and nixon of course did that when
he was you know that the washington post
was liberal that's why they were going
after him not because he was a crook so
that i think a lot of ways was the was a
phony
you know conservative argument for for
many many years but that's why it's so
it's unclear how
a restoration of the fairness doctrine
would um you know would work on today's
media landscape and
we do seem to have a lot of voices out
there
so you can find information where you
want to find it um
i mean i
i don't know you're not going to get i
mean even you know fox does have a few
liberal people on i used to do stuff at
fox myself
and it's you know i don't think that
it's going to you know
you're going to really win people over
by by getting a few more liberal voices
on fox and conservatives might say the
same thing about um
about msnbc although i don't think the
two are
truly equivalent uh but on you know it
goes back again to what we talked about
earlier about corporations and their
influence you have corporations
influence often with media entities when
you do see
you know the owners of sinclair
having a very very dis you know obvious
political strategy out there trying to
get their local stations to reflect
their
national conservative perspective
and you don't have anything like that
on
a liberal side there's no you know
major media operation that says we have
to you know do something like this but
the bigger impact is what we talked
about earlier was just you know
a lot of corporations corporate
interests private interests spending
money in politics and
we you know we've seen
that
certain politicians mainly democrats
although trump has done this now well
too
who connect with the public are able to
raise a lot of money from small
donations individual donations
and don't necessarily have to rely
on big corporate donations but we said
we start trump
doing both taking
donations from wealthy individuals and
corporations and you look at something
another scandal forgot another one to
add to the list the trump inauguration
fund
raised over 100 million dollars
from all sorts of folks from people who
have connections with russian oligarchs
don't have to tell us how they spent the
money
now apparently under investigation
so but i i think you know we talked
about the big money problem in
corporations having undue influence or
outsized influence in our politics
and um you know
that caller sounded like a bernie person
that's something that bernie sanders
made
a centerpiece of his campaign
last time and i presume we'll do again
if he runs again so what's your
view david corn of
billionaires on all sides george soros
the koch brothers tom steyer michael
bloomberg
getting involved with their money in
politics in a big way yeah i i would i
would i wish it wasn't necessary
in a lot of ways i wish we could have a
system where it was ideal driven
and there are other nations and there
are you know campaign finance reforms
where
people who run for office would be
publicly funded
you know you pay a dollar or two on your
taxes
and you know people run for office and
they you know
you can set up you know
benchmarks you know if you're a major
party and you get that party's
nomination
and you or you show x number
points in the polls or you raise x
amount of money yourself but only from
small donations to show that you're a
credible candidate then you get public
support and you don't have to go to
the billionaires
anymore now they still probably be able
to mount
influence campaigns you know
third-party issue
campaigns put on ads like that in which
case you know you need
tremendous transparency an ad saying we
need to cut taxes
this ad was paid for
said in a very slow voice by a very big
billionaire who doesn't like to pay
taxes you know something like like that
so i think you can find ways to sort of
you know make it work
you know you're never gonna get i think
money totally out of politics but
minimizing the advantage that one can
get from having a lot of money or
decreasing that advantage i think has to
be a goal
jim's in caliente california thanks for
holding jim please go ahead
thank you very much thank you for taking
my call and thank you mr corn for um
for this it's been great
my question is and i've been studying
politics well since since the late late
50s when i got involved in in the nixon
campaign in 60 as a very young teenager
but i was really big for nixon anyway
what's happened to the left especially
in the last 10 20 years uh
the the the tea party and the occupy
movement came up at the same time
the tea party had a big effect the
occupy movement died
obama came in in 08 with huge margins
and and it's just
died ever since i mean i i really don't
think we can blame
the conservative media by the way why
can't the liberals have people like rush
limbaugh i mean where are they or do
they exist
um
and why can't they be bankrolled um well
go ahead and finish jim and then we'll
get an answer here's your answer thank
you
there you go well he used the
bankroll there which is very interesting
and if you compare the tea party
to the occupy movement that
they both were on at the same time and
one took hold and had an
electoral influence and the other did
not so much at least not at that point
one big reason is money
what happened when the tea party started
was
some of the billionaires that you
mentioned earlier the koch brothers and
others rushed in
and gave money to various tea party
groups and used that you wanted to use
the tea party as a wedge
against democrats
and progressive minded people in
washington you know they were against
washington they're against you know um
obamacare they were
you know they want and so the koch
brothers and others funded these groups
to help get republicans into office who
would hold the line on taxes and who
would be in favor of deregulation
getting you know getting government out
of things so that was the instance where
moneyed interests
and the republican leaders themselves
saw this group
as a way to help them gain more seats
basically
and and and and uh embraced them
absorbed them and funded them
the occupy movement
was not seen that way by democrats and
certainly there are no billion there are
a few billionaires rushing in
to support the occupy movement
i mean
you know the truth of the matter is that
if you're going to challenge
you know the prerogatives of wall street
and of
corporate influence in america
you're not going to get a lot of support
from wall street in the corporate and
and that corporate class so there's a
little bit of an of an asymmetry here
so
and you do as callers have noted you
have democrats who often kind of
straddle the fence
between having a progressive populist
mindset and also wanting to be
pro-business
you know part because they believe that
in part because they want they believe
they need that money for themselves or
for the party
so the republican side is very
more
well
defined in a self-defined way
than the democratic side which has
always had this internal tension between
a business swing and an
anti-wall street wing wing
and so that makes it i think harder
that's that but that's one explanation
there and i do think
obama came in with a lot of
um
support
but you did have
republicans with the filibuster in the
senate
you know do everything they can to
thwart him and our system allowed for
that to happen there was a democratic
house the first year or two they passed
obamacare they got through the in the
senate but obama really you know i mean
again obama critics are not going to
accept this
but it is a fact that when it came to
his two biggest
moves i think when he became president
the stimulus package
and health care reform
he
reached out mightily to republicans
particularly in the senate to try to
come up with a plan that would have some
republican support and he courted them
he talked to them whether it was uh
grassley and olympia snow republicans in
the senate he on the on the stimulus he
added a tax cut which is not the way
that most democrats would want to do
stimulus because he wanted republican
support and all he ended up getting was
no no no
and it's now been widely reported that
the the opening days of the obama
administration republicans got together
and said we're not going to give him
anything
very hard in our system
even if you come in with a majority
as a president
to make things happen
and those are some of the things that
david corn talks about in his 2012 book
our 2011 book showdown
obama despite the public perception that
he was a cautious seeker of consensus
was a risk taker
well i in a different way i mean he was
not a risk taker in the way that you
know the progressive wing of the
democratic party wanted him to be he was
willing to take risks
in a
kind of a political way
after the 2010 election
when the
republicans gained back the house
basically said obama's presidency is
over
there were tax
cuts that were expiring from the bush
tax cut bill
and obama wanted
to extend the ones that applied to
middle and low-income americans but he
had run against the bush tax cuts for
the rich and that was a
very much a democratic
you know article of faith to oppose them
so he wanted to extend
the lower end tax cuts but not for the
for the wealthy people
and republicans had
a filibuster they could use in the in
the senate
and they refused
to do that
they they they kept saying we need to
extend all the tax cuts include those
for the wealthy and democrats are
basically urging obama to let them all
expire
so that all the tax cuts would go away
and then come back and just fight for
the to restore
the lower ones even though the house
republicans had just taken control of
the house which would make it much
difficult
and what he did at the end and i don't
think this was not really recognized at
the time
was he put together a package
negotiating with mitch mcconnell where
he added
a lot more middle-class low-income tax
cuts in addition to the ones that were
expiring that would created sort of a
mini stimulus bill
and he allowed the bush tax cuts for the
wealthy to continue
and
that was a risk on his part because it
was hard to see for progressivism for
democrats to see the benefit of the full
package
and he couldn't talk about it even as a
new stimulus because that would have
killed the deal it was like a secret
stimulus package
and so that was the risk he took and i
remember
i remember you know
you know hearing about the package and
the details and i was on i think i was
on npr and i believe i was on with ezra
klein and now at its
vox
and both of us came into the show
thinking that obama had not gotten a
good deal that this had been a cave-in
but then we start
on the show itself
as we're being asked about it we start
looking at you know the the the details
and what he got this tax break that tax
break earned income tax credit for the
poor
and we kind of like on air
turned a little bit so wait wait a
second you know if you do the numbers
he got like five times four times as
much tax relief for the poor and
middle class americans than it's going
to the wealthy and
he may have snooked mitch mcconnell here
so
but the only way he could have done that
was by not talking about it in that term
so that's why that was the sort of risk
that he was willing to take take
the blows from his own side
to do what he thought was right from a
policy perspective
lorenda vero beach florida email
do you have any political aspirations or
are you content in your role as an
investigative journalist
well you know like they all say i'm not
going to say never
you know i have no exploratory committee
no drive plans they say i have no plans
at this point in time right to run for
anything no no you thought about it
only in the way that anybody else has
i've never really been drawn to that
um
i'm not pat buchanan
although he did pretty well um
running
for
president i do think though it would be
interesting
i'm not saying about a presidential run
if reporters if journalists if you know
investigators people with that mindset
actually
tried in politics and and ran a local
officer you know that would be kind of
kind of interesting to see what someone
like that would do
in office you know
i'm really glad that you know if you
look at the
the new particularly the new democrats
who are coming in it's a group of people
it's just amazing in terms of diversity
and and and but also diversity and
background
you know a lot less just straight
lawyers a lot less people who've who
have just been you know creole career
politicians and i don't use that in a in
a pejorative way
uh we have a lot of career politicians
who do great stuff
so i mean having a congress you know we
talk about having a congress that looks
like america
um
and the democrats are working on that a
lot more than the republicans but
looking like america in terms of
your
professional experience so i don't know
you're going to run for something peter
do you know and i think you'll probably
agree with this i've really come to the
conclusion i don't often voice opinions
but
it takes a lot of
courage
to put yourself
in the ring regardless of position
regardless of how you feel philosophy it
takes a lot to put yourself out there no
you need a tremendously
thick skin
you know it's it it i mean the work
itself is hard i mean i don't think
people i mean we can we can you know
yell it about congress not doing this
not doing that but the actual day-to-day
task of being a congress person or
senator is hard i mean in part it's
because of the money raising as well
because they spend so much time doing
something that they a lot of them really
hate to do
but just the scheduling and the they
need you know there are so many
complicated issues out there and to be
caught up on them i mean i'm very
frustrated when i go to hearings
and
you know i watch hearings on c-span and
you see like uh these members
questioning mark zuckerberg like oh
so on facebook i can send someone a
message
i mean it's like okay maybe if we had
somebody who had who had a career in
cyber or something or media they might
get to the point quicker and better so
um but
it is a hard to do and it's you got to
take a risk to do it you got to you know
and and it's it if you lose it doesn't
help your career
um that's for damn sure often
so i don't know but i but i would you
know i i i like the idea of having
a people's house with
people in it
help us to understand washington mr corn
uh how are you and are you and do you
know pat buchanan at all you yeah yeah
would you consider him a friend of yours
no no no and i i would say i'm friendly
with pat
um pat did a radio show
um years ago
buchanan and friends it was three hours
but it was like crossfire
each hour being a different subject and
there'd be
pat is the conservative then he would
have a liberal co-host which would
change and then there'd be a liberal
guest and a conservative guest on the
given issue of that hour and i was one
of the rotating co-hosts with pat
and so uh we would fence a little bit
and i would grow the conservative and he
would drill the liberal and um i've
always said this that i thought pat was
easy fun
to work with he was joyful
in his political
um
you know
boxing skills he really liked a good
fight and he liked a strong opponent he
didn't want to you know um
you know make it easier for himself so i
always you know and now i
i
agree with him on positions no i didn't
agree with him on positions there was
the issues had been raised about whether
he was an anti-semite or engaged in
anti-semitism
and um
personally i didn't
sense there is any animus towards for
him towards you know
anybody because of their
uh religion creed color background
whatever but i actually wrote one or two
pieces which i try to understand
the accusations of anti-semitism against
him and i just came to the belief that
he was a tribalist he really will felt
that like his tribe
working class white catholics
was at war or not
competed with other tribes and it would
and that life
in the world was a zero-sum game and one
group got ahead only at the expense of
another
and you know if you want to call that
anti-semitism racism whatever you can
but that was
how i saw him but i anyway i got along
with that
and i've gotten along with a lot of
conservatives in town not with all but
some who you know who i've worked with
on
shows and so on
i find now the culture of washington
though has changed
it used to be a lot more
the divide used to be more republican
democrat conservative liberal and now
it's you know trump has made it
what i would call rational irrational
what you could say trump
or anti-trump and so
i find myself having a jolly old time
with people like charlie sykes and max
boot and and jennifer rubin and bill
crystal
michael steele
all republican conservatives who have
you know
moved away from the republican party uh
because of trump
and i do
think in our political culture
that's become the dividing line now
less so
conservative
liberal and it's it's it's it's it's an
interesting shift i don't know
if it holds beyond
the trump years what does it mean
we have one hour left in our
conversation with author david corn he
mentioned that he was at the miami book
fair he and his co-author on russian
roulette michael isakoff were down there
we want to show you a little bit of
their talk this is mostly michael
isikoff and then we'll be back live
again
i just want to start out talking a
little bit about recent events first of
all yeah obviously we're all sort of on
pins and needles to see how
the robert mueller investigation is
going to reach its grand conclusion um
you know there are
a lot of signs out there about some uh
uh indictments to come perhaps imminent
of a few other uh characters who we talk
about in the book and then there's the
question of you know will he have a
report that we'll see uh about
everything he's found uh in um in the
course of his investigation but
however that plays out and i wish i
could tell you we know we don't um
we have some clues but you know um
we've all been wrong before
um speak for yourself
[Laughter]
okay we do know a lot and uh we know a
lot so it's unfolded and i just
just i just want to talk about
you know
the events over the last week because i
think they're are so illustrative um
you know
we can't tell you whether
mueller is going to find the smoking gun
uh the conclusive email or intercept
that will show donald trump or somebody
in his campaign was actively
communicating or coordinating with the
russians during the 2016 election but
whenever you have questions about that
you know nobody fuels the story and
gives it further legs better than donald
trump himself
and um
you know go back to
last weekend in paris the 100th
uh anniversary ceremony um commemorating
the armistice that ended world war one
um you know a very somber uh ceremony i
don't know how many of you watched it
you know um and there's you know trump
you know glumly sitting there uh
um being lectured to by macron uh
about patriotism and nationalism and um
you know looking very out of sorts
through the whole thing
and then
suddenly his eyes light up and he breaks
out into a spontaneous smile something
you almost never see with donald trump
and why there's vladimir putin looking
at him just a couple of seats
away and putin gives him the fun the
thumbs up i mean you know we've all
scratched our head trying to understand
this strange weird relationship between
the president of the united states and
the president of the russian federation
why he's the one guy
trump seems to be so fond of so
protective of so friendly with he could
denounce you know justin trudeau in
canada that great threat to american uh
uh
american sovereignty um
but uh you know he's always there to
stand by vladimir putin um we've got we
i we go into a lot about the trump uh
putin relationship in the book but i
mean it is it is behavior like that that
just you know spontaneous smile at the
sight of vladimir putin that raises so
many questions about what's going on
here and i'll just cap it with
just um the other day
after trump had to sit through hours of
preparations with his lawyers for
answering robert mueller's questions you
know something that you know clearly uh
enrages him and causes him to go on this
tweet storm once again denouncing
mueller the witch-hunt the angry
democrats it was all a setup why aren't
they investigating hillary clinton and
right in the middle of that he throws in
a line why didn't the fbi
get the dnc server and you know for
those of you who follow this closely
there's only one reason to throw that in
there and that is to somehow
raise doubt about whether the russians
did this at all and this comes after you
know not just the unanimous findings of
the us intelligence community that the
russians hacked the dnc the russians
gave the emails to wikileaks the
russians engaged in this disinformation
campaign the russians exploited american
social media they did it all but also
the unbelievable indictment that mueller
brought last summer against identifiable
russian military intelligence agents
that laid out chapter and verse who did
it how they did it
you know the the actual quotes from the
intercepted emails of the russians
communicating with each other and with
wikileaks delivering the uh stolen
uh dnc emails to uh julian assange at
wikileaks on july 14 2016 barely a week
before
wikileaks dumps it on the eve of the
convention
and yet
there's donald trump who's been briefed
on this multiple times
laying all the evidence out clinging to
this idea that somehow it was that
proverbial 400 pound guy in the living
room on his sofa who's responsible for
the whole thing what what trump aided
and abetted was a federal crime um
mueller has brought you know a
indictment of identifiable people for
violating federal law the russian
military intelligence agents who stole
those dnc emails by the way a
massively larger theft than the
than the watergate burglars who stole
from the dnc in 1972
um
it was a a theft of internal documents
and then used for political effect but i
want to switch the conversation a little
bit to um how the u.s government here
and its response because i think we
document in the book that this was
while all this was going on everything
that david talked about
there was a
really
major intelligence failure by the u.s
government comparable in many ways to
the intelligence failure that
led up to the events of of 9 11 and a
major policy failure by the obama
administration as well in its response
but let's talk about the intelligence
failure um uh to begin with as we talk
about in the book there were
multiple warnings that the u.s
intelligence community had
about what the russians were up to
we talked about write about a secret
source inside the kremlin in 2014
who was laying it all out to a u.s
government official about
what putin was up to about the plans
that russian intelligence had to
destabilize
western
democracies including the united states
cyber attacks disinformation propaganda
all of that
was being communicated you know this
secret source was telling the us
government you don't understand what's
going on here there is something very
big there is something very major that
is being planned and all this was being
communicated back to washington to
senior government officials who frankly
really weren't paying sufficient
attention
and that was david korn's co-author
michael isikoff he's co-written two
books with mr corn russian roulette and
hubris
mr corn who was ted shackley and why was
he worthy of a book
ted shankly was the subject of my first
book called blonde ghost
he was a ci officer who had been in the
say for 30 years
and i it was a biography of him and and
sort of in some ways a biography of the
cia because he had been involved in so
many of the most
consequential cia actions which
a lot of them included failures but he
was involved in spying in berlin in the
50s
involved with the cia's
operation against fidel castro and cuba
in the in the 60s he was in charge of
the miami station
for the cia that led that fight he then
was in charge of the secret war in laos
during the vietnam war when the cia put
together basically its own
army there of indigenous people to fight
in the war without
telling anybody
and things did not end up well for the
indigenous tribes people who were part
of that then he was a cia station chief
in vietnam
and
argue had a hand in our ultimate failure
there
and then he was in charge of the east
asia division
in charge of the western hemisphere
division and was rising up the ranks and
got to be
the number two
in the operations directorate the
operation that does all the espionage
and covert activity and secret warfare
and then got caught in the iran contra
scandal
involved with a guy
who was an arms dealer
ed wilson
and that kind of ended his ci career so
in a lot of ways i thought the arc of
his career
was the arc of the cia throughout much
of the cold war
and there are a lot of good spy stories
a lot of good you know um
stories of about
that many some end up being tragic but
show that
i think unfortunately for a lot of the
cia's cold war activity
particularly when it came to espionage
getting intelligence
uh it had a really
tough
time a bad record getting stuff on on
the soviet block in the 50s you know
getting information and acting on it
against cuba getting information in
vietnam
these are areas where
say i really fell short
you know and areas in which it often did
things that you know
were of questionable
ethics perhaps or legality but anyway uh
he's was a fascinating character
and um it took me five years to do that
book that was a very very hard project
it was my first book
and i had no idea what i was getting
into
did he talk to you
not for years i mean i noticed i
contacted him when i started writing the
book
and every
six months i sent i called or sent a
letter asking if i could sit down and
talk to him
and
he just refused refused refused
at some point i got a message from his
daughter
his daughter wanted to meet me
why did she want to meet me because she
did not know much about her father's
past by that i don't mean his cia passed
she knew he worked for the cia but his
family passed i had done all this
research and i tracked the family back
and he had had a weird upbringing
in which his mom had worked as a hostess
at a you know
in a new york city restaurant and met a
very wealthy man
and moved down to
palm beach with him and for some time
her mother who
basically only spoke polish so ted
shackley's grandmother took care of him
so i tracked all this down and i knew
more about
his family past than she did
she knew a few things i knew a few other
things and we kind of like
put our notes together and came up with
the best story
uh that we that i could find about his
upbringing but in any event aft you know
after a few years he finally relented
and under very very
stringent circumstances
he agreed to
talk to me i had to present questions in
advance and he
wanted it recorded um but he wanted
somebody
he didn't want me to walk away with a
recording of it myself
so we had to find a mutual party who
would hold on to the tape
um
and i was told by people who knew him
that for all those years
i was writing the book he didn't believe
i was working on a book
he believed i was part of some operation
to get him
that there was some other motivation
there's something going on he didn't
quite know what it was and i was a
journalist i was an established
journalist i had written i was i was a
washington
editor for the nation magazine i'd
written lots of articles no books lots
of articles i had been on c-span i mean
i was publicly known to be a journalist
yet he still believed there was
something else going on he couldn't
figure out what it was so finally after
four years or so he agreed to see me
and
he was
i think fair to say even he's gone now
he was not a very self-reflective person
and it was very hard for me to get him
to
give expansive answers or explain his
motivations why he did everything he was
very much
by the book and by the official account
so
to me it was great to spend two hours
with him
having spent four years researching him
but i didn't really get much out of him
material to use and i couldn't really
get him to reflect on the failures or
successes
of the cia writ large in his own career
if somebody picked up blonde ghosts
today
what would they get
american history personal history yeah i
think it's it's you know you you we
don't know much about the people who
who live these lives i mean what he did
he did in our name the ci acts in the
name of the u.s citizen
and i think you'd end up getting a a
a
picture of the type of person who lives
that life but you also would get a a
history
of the dark side of the cold war
you know they sent
he was responsible for recruiting agents
to go behind the iron curtain to east
germany and poland and
czechoslovakia and he was part of a big
city program to do that
they almost all got rounded up they
almost all got killed and john le carre
has written some novels that that are
predicated on those type of operations
and we don't really know much about that
we don't know much about the people who
went are the people who sent them so but
you learn about that you learn about
real truth about this what happened with
the cia
in cuba and how that might have even had
a connection with the
assassination of john f kennedy so
there's a lot of i think seminal
episodes that this man that ted checkly
was directly involved in on the secret
side
so um
i'm very proud of the book i think it
reads like real life la carre
and which is my
goal and i think it still
still stands up as a as a good read
today
when did you decide to write a novel
well that's a good question when i mean
i i don't remember the moment it
happened
i mean i've always wanted to write
novels and and i've always enjoyed
fiction and i've written short stories
as well
um i grew up loving novels um
so i thought always in the back of my
mind i had an idea to do it
and after spending
you know basically five years on blonde
ghost
which was really this was pre-internet
it would take me months and months just
to locate
sources people who worked in the cia
with ted shackley who would talk to me i
made i spent hours on the telephone
talking to someone who might know
someone who might know someone and then
finding that person then spending a year
courting them and getting them to talk
to me
i had
a lot of lunches
at vietnamese restaurants in arlington
virginia
with xcia guys who liked to drink a lot
of beer
in the middle of the day
and i would find addresses i would knock
on people's doors and just show up
and try to talk to them so
it was a lot of painstaking work
to locate people and get them to talk
and a lot of that history has some of it
has been declassified since then but
getting documents um was really
difficult
the legendary psy hirsch helped me at
some point
with some documents that he had gotten
but in any event i think
my guess is because i don't remember my
my guess is after that experience the
idea of sitting home
alone in my apartment and just making
stuff up
was really rather appealing
do you see more novels in your future
i have a lot
in me that i've thought about i i i
haven't really sat down
to write any yet
so it's it's conceivable it's possible
um
viewers might be interested to know that
in general
the non-fiction market
is more profitable in a lot of ways than
fiction unless you're really
top seller of a household name
so um i've had two kids who are you know
going to be in college next year
i still need to think about
author authoring
as somewhat of a
commercial enterprise for me but i would
love to write more fiction well we
always ask our guests what their
favorite books are and the first three
that you list are all novels all the
king's men the great gatsby and v by
thomas pinchon yeah i'm not i don't know
if there's any significance that they
put the fiction first
but
i mean i assume a lot of people who
watch book tv have read the great gatsby
but i would real i mean all the king's
men still is to me
is perhaps the great american novel it
is it is about
politics it's about a huey long figure
but it's really more about
um human nature
and making hard decisions
dealing with secrets of the past i mean
tremendously great themes a lot of
themes that that fitzgerald
did more obviously in the great gatsby
um
but all the king's men has a tremendous
epic and gothic sweep to it um so
i mean i haven't read it in years but i
did read it you know i've read it
several times
and that's you know if if i meet a young
person who says like what book should i
read
i haven't read
that's always on the top of my
of my list
the next three
non-fiction the power broker robert caro
a bright shining lie neal sheehan and
lawrence in arabia
yeah it was very hard i mean your
producer said what are your favorite
books and
you know and and and
you know i have a lot i also said
anything by le carre anything by graham
greene anything by william kennedy who
did the albany trilogy and wrote a great
book called roscoe and anything by el
doctoro you know so they're they're
they're authors who i who i love and to
me it's always tragic
that you know several of them now are
gone and we will never get another
gram green book we will never get
another book by edgar doctoro um
but for the the three nonfiction i mean
i'm sure i'm leaving a lot of things out
i looked at my bookshelf and thought
about it hard the power broker
is a long book about a guy named robert
moses
who was
he ran
the the port of you know
an authority not a state government
not an elected official but an authority
in new york city and was in charge of
bridges tunnels highways
sounds kind of mundane
but he got all the money from the tolls
and he got to decide
where the highways would and parkways
would go
and some are beautiful and others
totally destroyed neighborhoods and he
was really a dictator in a way and
shaping
what new york city
manhattan but also the bureau boroughs
came to look like in the 40s 50s 60s 70s
he did it for a long time
and
it's some you know it by robert carroll
who's one of the best you know and most
obsessive biographers out there
who's still working on his lyndon
johnson books
and it's a great story about power
about a oversized personality a lot of
people
you know millions of new yorkers and
others were affected by him without
knowing about his existence
and in the end you know there was a lot
of scandal and and corruption that was
exposed by a bunch of young reporters
who came together from all the new york
papers the times the daily news long
island news day who started looking at
him
and
in a quasi-collaborative way because
they also competed
they ended up exposing him and kind of
bringing him down
um
it's a mar just a marv and the
storytelling in the book is great it's
just it's just the model for you know
any journalist who wants to do
non-fiction writing
um even more so than all the
president's men by woodward and
bernstein which is a great book it's
about one thing and it's about how that
you know they're how they pursued a
story
great book great movie but the power
broker
shows you what non-fiction
journalism should really aspire to
and bright shining light by neil sheehan
does the same thing
in vietnam
uh falls one guy john paul vance
van who um
had a advisory role there
at a
i won't give much away but an extremely
interesting and somewhat dark personal
life
and he tells
neil sheen who covered the war for the
new york times and broke the story of
the pentagon papers
he's referenced in the recent movie the
post
um just does a great job of of of
showing how personal decisions
and individual decisions
you know affected the course of this
tragic war in vietnam
that took the lives of so many americans
and so many vietnamese and laotians and
others
and the last
lawrence in arabia not lawrence of
arabia now lawrence of arabia happens to
be i think this is a coincidence one of
my favorite movies
and if any viewer has not seen it i
don't care what your age is
it takes three hours you gotta watch it
but nevertheless
it's about a real character t lawrence
who
was a a british military officer who was
sent to organize
arab armies against the turks in world
war one
and lawrence
in arabia the book
of
by scott anderson
is about the real life t.e lawrence but
also about
five or six other
operatives spies who were in the middle
east at that time as they all were
jockeying to draw the lines and form
alliances
and it shows how their actions
basically gave us the modern
arab world you know in terms of
geopolitical
you know boundaries and borders
and
how very things got so screwed up from
there
but it's it's sort of a um
there's a lot of skullduggery
there's like a mara
mata hari character
um and there and it's really like oh my
god you know a dozen people
um all from various interests german
interests turkishiness from zionist
interests
um british interests
all kind of like
in the same world interacting with each
other sometimes like meeting
also they'll meet in cairo and look at
each other early like i know what you're
doing here i mean it's like casa blanca
writ large in a in a real world
and um and the book is it was just a
fabulous read one of my favorite
nonfiction reads of the last couple
years but i am sure
i'm leaving out
a a fair many books there well we've got
some more and we'll show those as we go
but i've talked enough and i want to get
the callers in here joanna damascus
maryland thanks for holding you're on
with author david corn
hi david um i
would really like to hear you discuss
something that i think is the paramount
issue of our time and that is the rapid
rise of nationalism and autocrats here
in the united states and throughout the
world
this issue nationalism is what was the
key impetus for both world wars world
war 1 and world war ii and i have to
tell you it absolutely terrifies me
well i i i assure you and i would use
the word tribalism even more the
nationalism
i think our inability
to
you know make bridges with people who
are different than we are and connect
and see a wider view
is a true impediment to dealing with
some of the very real problems that we
face in america that we face in the
world
um
and i do think that you know
biological uh evolutionary biologists
and other scientists would tell you that
part of our brain brain is programmed to
you know see like as like you know
people look like you people think like
you people maybe share the same religion
and to
cluster and collect into groups like
that
and there's power to that we you had to
do it obviously for our survival once
upon a time and it can and you can
maximize your own ability if you
if you join together with a group of
people who share values the dark side of
course is that you then look at others
as others
and not be able to join
with other groups in pursuit of joint
targets and goals
and that has long been exploited
here we've had demagogues in american
history you know i mentioned huey long
earlier but there were you know demigods
of the right and and the left you know
you had someone like george wallace you
had racists who um led you know white
people to kill black people in the south
after the civil war i talked about that
earlier as well so there's a strong
impulse for people to
move in that direction and people
exploit it
they do it for their own
person their own political ambitions
sometimes to make money
and um
it's really tough to figure out what to
do we see this with trump
fanning
this immigration the immigration issue
into a crisis it's not a crisis it's a
part you know it can be a problem there
are things to work out there it's not
threatening our nation the way he says
it is
that makes it very hard then to have a
reasonable conversation
about what we should do about border
security about undocumented
people who live and work
among us
here in the united states
and you know you say this is the the
most important issue in a way you're
right because one of the most pressing
issues we have now
of course is climate change
and i've been talking i'm working on a
project and talking to some scientists
recently and
you know it's very hard not to get
depressed about it
the problem is so big the possible
consequences are so enormous
and
they will lead to
other problems
know droughts
populations shifting economic uh
tribulations
um
that
may
be like
conflicts we have not seen in human
history
and yet the only way to deal with this
is a we in america have to you know
be able to do what we can but then join
with other nations
and at the same time we deal with
fundamental
the rise of fundamentalism which in
sentences leads to fundamental terrorism
and the inability to
bridge those gaps
so i mean it
we talked earlier peter about
what shapes human history is it
decisions at the top or
people at the bottom and it's obviously
both
and on some issues that don't
knock on your door
you know like if you can't get a job
that knocks on your door if your kid
can't afford college that knocks on your
door if you need an operation you're
sure won't cover it
and you you know and and the republicans
have eviscerated obamacare you can't get
it through that that knocks on your door
i got we those things all have to be
dealt with but there are some issues
that don't knock on your door
climate change
is knocking a little bit you got the
forest fires you have the tragedy in
paradise you saw what happened you know
other parts of the world where the
waters are rising and taking away land
from people
but for most americans it's not really
quite knocking on the door the way the
other knocks come in
and that's i think an area where
you need the leadership
you need people with the scientific
community they're speaking
and now people who are elected as
representatives to to judge and to
evaluate
what
the nation needs what their community
needs
not just in the immediacy but also in
the long run
need to sort of
highlight that and and in some ways
educate
people who are pressed by these other
matters
so um
nationalism tribalism all that
gets in the way of having those sort of
conversations
two tweets first one is from mike in
your opinion how is this all going to
end
impeachment resignation losing 2020
election prison destruction of trump inc
or does he somehow survive
i you know
i make no predictions
whatsoever i mean
every day
i probably have you know a dozen
conversations along these lines i don't
know what's going to happen with the end
of the mueller investigation there may
not be a
full report that tells people what
mueller found he has no obligation to
produce one he has to submit a report on
his prosecutorial decisions why
prosecuted this case
he could do a long
explanation of i looked into this matter
give us all the facts but i decided it
didn't there was no crime to prosecute
or you could just say here are the eight
cases i prosecuted and why blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah be done with it
so we don't know
what he's going to do in terms of final
indictments or a final report
um
you know it's unclear you know to you
can't really predict any of trump's own
actions
you know who he's going to hire who he's
going to fire what's he what he's going
to do with china we're going to you know
all we can do is is say that there's a
trend line of chaos
disruption and disorder and the
inability to work with others
and that will likely continue
um
what does that mean with him
i don't know i mean i i all i know about
trump is that
he has this the the narcissistic
personality perspective on the world
where everything is about him and he's
the center of all that people like that
don't resign don't run away if they're
going down they blow up everything with
them or at least they try to
impeachment in the house
right now
the leadership of the house house
is generally saying they're not
interested in impeachment i'm not a
political strategist my advice to them
was would be as we've talked about
already today
there are at least a dozen if not two or
three dozen scandals you can identify
are
allegations of corruption that
any congress doing oversight should look
at
i think they should you know very
deliberately look at those while passing
legislation and tending to the other
side of government
and you know say are we are going to do
our fulfill oversight responsibilities
and you know at the end of that we'll
see where we are we'll see where he is
we'll see where the nation is
um
so
we we we've been in in uncharted waters
i don't see any chart appearing about
where we will be
um but
you know the political trend line of
this election was not good for the
republicans was not good for trump and
it showed a tremendous increase in civic
action
so i hope
and i doubt that's going to
evaporate second tweet resist with hope
is the twitterer do you think like the
nixon tapes there will be a smoking gun
revealed in mueller's report
well as we talked about earlier i think
the smoke i think they're already
multiple smoking guns
i think the fact that donald trump aided
in the bed of the russian attack
is proven you don't need a smoking gun
and that in any other
reasonable world maybe you know we
talked about stephen hawking earlier in
his latest book he talks about the
theory that there are infinite universes
that basically every you know anything
that could have happened somewhere did
happen so in another universe
uh where you know
where the where the political culture
the political media culture has not been
as perverted by trump as it has been
um the smoking guns that we know already
the deal with russia
um you know the the revelation that he
was told that russia was attacking the
election and he still said it wasn't all
those smoking guns might have
you know done something
so i you know again i go back to my
earlier point about robert mueller we
don't know what he's going to do we
don't know if he's going to do any more
indictments we don't know if he's going
to put out a report that's going to have
any evidence and
brings me to maybe a larger point
the issue in some
ways here is who tell the people
russians attacked an american election
i can't think of any more profound
matter
for the american public to know
everything about
yet the house intelligence investigation
run by republicans was a circus
and collapsed and was shuttered the
senate intelligence committee
we don't know what's happening neither
one have held any public hearings
about these issues really about they
they they they've not called up any
witnesses about the trump tower meeting
trump's project in moscow
maybe this will come with the democrats
controlling the house intelligence
committee but we don't have anybody who
sees it as their job to give us a full
accounting it's not robert mueller's job
his job is to prosecute
cases that he can find so
we really didn't need a real
congressional investigation like we had
with watergate or irene contra or even
the the clinton campaign financing uh
campaign finance abuses in the 90s or we
needed
an independent commission like the 911
commission
and so far we have none of that
conventional wisdom or washington wisdom
is that the mueller investigation team
has been
not a leaky ship
um i haven't got any leaks from them
i've been pretty amazed
um by
little that leaked that seemed to come
from them
in washington it's really the lawyers
who leak a lot of ways and everybody who
is
you know involved with this who goes
before
you know the grand jury was questioned
has an attorney
and attorneys often have reasons to leak
out information to help or help their
client or hurt somebody else's client
and so they leak
members of congress
leak
um
we know that house republicans
on the intelligence committee were
leaking material to
distract from the core of the
investigation
so there are a lot of leaks going on
around there
but i'll be damned if i see many coming
from robert mueller's um
outfit i mean i mean
when he puts out the indictments or the
what they call the informations when
people plead about say the michael cohen
one recently we there was a lot of
material that we had no idea about
wow
wow and so
they
i mean my hat's off to him as a citizen
as a journalist i'd like to see
more leaks but i know you know anytime
i've asked them anything it's very very
buy the book
buy the book
mark michigan city indiana please go
ahead with your question or comment for
david corn
yes thank you uh mr corn
um i'm convinced now that i'd like to
buy
one of your books i think i'll do that
today
thank you russian
russian roulette i just want to say for
you mr izakov i've been following you
guys very closely and i'm i've never
really been in a big follower of
politics but
since mr trump was a a candidate i've
been watching the news at least to two
hours a day i'll get two hours a day
just a little bit of
fox but mostly
msnbc i just want to tell you guys to
keep up the good fight i do have a
question at the end of my comments
well thank you for that what's your
question
uh the question
is in all of your investigating mr corn
have you uh suspected or found any of
the members
of our current or past senate
to be uh
involved in this russian fiasco that
we're faced with
well that's a good question and and i
know what he's getting at because
the republicans
have denied or
dismissed or downplayed
the russian attack and the scandal
and it goes back to
the campaign itself and mike and i write
about this
uh in in the book russian were led that
when the obama administration you know
realized what the russians were doing
they were attacking the election and
perhaps trying to you know
affect the results
and they were also probing into state
election systems and that freaked out
the white house perhaps even more than
what they were doing in terms of
impeding hillary clinton
they reached out
to mitch mcconnell senate majority
leader and house speaker paul ryan the
two top republicans so this is underway
the russians are attacking us we'd like
to have a bipartisan joint response
publicly so you guys join us and we'll
say this is happening and we'll try to
figure out how we're going to respond
mitch mcconnell
particularly more more so than paul ryan
said no said this is a [ __ ] issue
don't want to be involved with this
people who worked for obama who knew
about this high up in his foreign policy
national security team were astounded
they were astounded that they could not
get the leader
of the u.s senate
to join them
in speaking out about this and having a
united front and one reason they
couldn't do that was because donald
trump was out there saying this isn't
happening
this is nothing this is a hoax
so that would mean he would have to be
on the different side
than his than the nominee of his party
and
they went through poor ryan ryan tried
to convince mcconnell to do something
but the end of the day mcconnell
wouldn't and ryan wouldn't do anything
on his own
so i mean
this to me is astounding
and i don't think they're doing this
because they're on the payroll of the
russians
but just for political purposes they
would not
come together and says a lot about
where we are at a nation this point
because i keep coming back to this
this was not russian meddling
this was a russian attack information
warfare and we describe in the book how
they had been thinking about this and
developing this strategy
for years not necessarily attacking the
the election in this fashion specific
way but doing these type of things not
against the united states only but
against other countries in the west um
england
getting involved with brexit france
getting involved in the election there
and other nations like estonia and
ukraine
um they've been doing this
so here was you know the republican
leadership saying we're not going to
join you
uh for politics and then ever since then
you had a few republicans say a few
things about this matter but by and
large
the republicans on the house side
punted and they try to make this all
about
the democrats getting a dossier to get a
wiretap on one former
you know
trump campaign advisor
and the senate they're still working on
it but they don't really talk much about
it these days and
the news came out was it like three
weeks ago peter that um that the trump
tower
project had gone longer in 2016 and that
michael cohen had worked on it and
it shows that trump you know had this
conflict of interest
correct me if i'm wrong when the mueller
report came out on cohen yeah yeah
correct me if i'm wrong i've yet to hear
a prominent republican
say anything about
trump
negotiating or
trying to enlist putin's own office to
earn hundreds of million dollar hundreds
of millions of dollars while running as
a presidential candidate
i mean i'm kind of astonished they won't
even say oh i'm even troubled by that i
don't even see jeff flake ben sasse even
the people who ring their hands once in
a while
and and and that too astonishes me and i
don't know i don't you know think that
the russians necessarily have anything
on them
which is what you know you see on
twitter and social media people
suggesting that
i think they've just you know have
thrown in the towel
and just sort of you know
we're with trump you know sink or swim
and you know all the other values that
we care about
don't matter as much
three more of david corn's favorite
books
um
two or non-fiction we'll ask him about
third fear and loathing on the campaign
trail by hunter s thompson everybody
should read that at some point uh just
kids by rocker patty smith that was
nominated for a national book award as
well in the island at the center of the
world by russell shorto not familiar
that's a great book it's about the very
beginning of manhattan which was settled
by the dutch
and this is one thing that i'm
i'm really i'm a very envious person
of good reporting and great books i mean
it kills me to see somebody do something
that that's so fantastic what what what
russell found
was there was an archive
of all the legal and formal records of
the first dutch colony
that was written kind of an ancient
dutch
and
they were discovered by a
archivist librarian i think in albany
and he learned how to and and the way
they're written you mean you know like a
magnifying glass you have to look at
each letter make out each word and this
guy learned ancient dutch
to read these documents
and they tell basically the story
of the first first dutch
colony at the tip of manhattan who was
there the citizens you know all the who
broke laws what the laws were who owed
what
money
and from all these records he was able
to to create this account
of this thriving
this was a really interesting thing
diverse
community of people from all
different religions different parts of
the world it wasn't just straight dutch
and they all got found themselves
you know
you know somewhat adventurers
living you know and they were at former
pirates they were prostitutes there were
people who came to seek their fortune
and there were politics between the
people running the you know the colony
the settlement and the people back home
in holland that were the trading company
and the government that was that was
supposedly in charge of this
it's a marvelous book you can make a
game of thrones type series out of this
it is so riveting and
he really proves his point like that you
know we now look at manhattan as a
thriving example of the melting pot
and it you know and his point was it
doesn't come from like the brits
who ended up
gaining control
of manhattan
but it came from prior to that
so i mean i i grew up outside of new
york i think of myself as somewhat of a
new yorker
and it was just a
riveting riveting book
julia santa rosa california hi julia
hello thank you for taking my call
um david corn i just want to tell you
how much i appreciate your work
and having um
the truth be told
to everyone and i just
feel alarmed like that one lady did that
what's happened to our government why
aren't people standing up these
republicans democrats whoever it is for
us
i feel renewed hope with the new
congress
i hope they stand bold
and just tell him our taxpayer dollars
are not going to pay for that wall
and these people that he says the
federal workers that are behind him he's
wrong they live paycheck to paycheck
and they need their money and he needs
to just stop with his child his antics
and
listen to us
and i
you know i could go on and on but i i
really can't um so let's let's leave
that julia um you've have you been
saying what you're saying for the last
two years
before that okay does it has it made a
difference
does it make you feel better
what's your endgame
my endgame is hopefully if we have to
wait the two till 2020 to get him out
if we can't do nothing before then
please let's rise up and come together
as a country republican democrat i don't
care to get our country back and get our
face back to the world
well thank you ma'am i said this a
moment ago i do think that trump's
election
led to this increase of civic activism
you know you saw it first through the
women's march and you saw i know a lot
of people who got engaged in the
election
in the midterm election we just had who
were never engaged before
and um i think
you know for you know for democrats for
progressives
um who care about
income inequality
climate change um
you know
a decent social safety net
network net um other environmental
matters that there's has to be a
realization
that none of this
is ever permanent
that you know no battle you know no
political battle is ever really fully
won that if you care about these issues
you got to stay
engaged
um
you know the woman's right to choose you
know it goes back and forth that that
will never be
i think you know an issue that that that
ends
so if you have a particular perspective
on that
you've got to stay engaged
and you know trump with his extreme
you know
behavior and ex excesses highlights that
um and
they and with and with the republican
controlling both houses of congress for
the first two years of his term
showed that you know if you don't have
checks and balances
what can happen
so it was a
i think a wake-up call to some and you
know the only advice i give to any
american
is if you give a damn about anything
you gotta remain engaged and you gotta
keep fighting if you you know that's
what the nra does it's what people in
every town the gun safety group has to
do
and it's unfortunate that takes events
like parkland
to make you need to get people out but
you know my daughter is a high school
student she got very engaged and led
some of the local area walkouts high
school walkouts in support of the um
parkland kids when they were walking out
and going to the state house there i
mean this is really what makes
america great i mean you know this is
what makes america great you have to
make it a great make it great again
makes it great is the ability
of anybody to get out there if they give
a damn
and try to rally others around them
and have an impact
on what happens now i think it's very
hard
you know we talked about campaign
finances and corporate inference
influences and dollars and it's hard to
go it's hard hard to fight city hall
it's hard to do all these things but
in the past
you know
if you know women had to fight for the
vote
americans had to fight for freedom
a lot of you know workers had to fight
not to uh work 80 hours a week and to
have labor protections
these are all things that had to be
fought for
and we know we can all get complacent
and think that we've gotten them but
on many fronts you gotta you know keep
at it and along that same line here's an
email from judy in norwood massachusetts
good morning enjoying your conversation
with david corn did you notice that most
of your callers were women today i do
feel that trump has ignited the wrath of
american womanhood
note the women's marches and movement
the increase in women taking up the
energy to run and win political
competitions
go girls and go c-span is how she
concludes that
and
this is a facebook comment from kathy
i see referring to you i see he has no
liking for republicans and is probably
part of the never trump movement but am
i supposed to believe that there were no
democratic scandals he needed to
investigate oh but i i i have in the
past i mean i've written about democrats
who were caught up in
mainly money of campaign finance
scandals but during the 90s
there were campaign financial scandals
about the clinton presidential campaign
and i covered that one of my
very very first stories
and and when i came to washington was
about
uh a political action committee a pac
run by dick gephart who was the top
democrat in the house then
that was supposedly set up to help other
candidates
but was really a stalking horse not even
a kind of a slush fund for his own you
know political operation as he was
thinking about running for president and
i remember calling people who who
donated to that you know meeting average
citizens and and asking what they were
donating the money for and they all said
oh it's for his presidential campaign
um
so you know i i have you know written
about democrats you know and at mother
jones
um we've written a bunch of stories when
hillary clinton was secretary of state
about issues she had with promoting
fracking
um so you know i
um
have not limited
my focus only to republicans these days
you know trump and the administration
the people in power are the ones who
um
i think warrant
the most um
the most concentration most focused
another email this is from maria
have you ever come across a serious
piece of information that you did not
divulge
yeah all the time every journalist will
say that because i maybe couldn't
confirm it
or people tell me things off the record
all the time and i try to get them on
the record to say things um
i
yeah i mean i
some once told me
a tremendously significant story about
dick cheney that
um
i believed to be true he was in a
position to know it
but uh
i could not talk to the a more direct
source
and i couldn't confirm it so
you know
in my line of work i'm often getting
leads tips
pointers
on material that i can't
as a journalist
can't publish can't post because of the
rules of reporting
it can be very very frustrating i've
spent
i've spent months and sometimes years
pursuing stories i
okay
democrat i i i somebody who i
was a lobbyist told me about how some
major corporations were blackmailing
a prominent democratic
chair chair of a house committee
i guess this is back in the
90s
and
uh there was dirt on him that a few
corporations had and they were using it
to leverage him and the person who told
me i
truly i truly believed
uh and and
i tried really hard to confirm that
story
but i could never do that so i didn't
write it and publish it and i can't say
now who the person was
but yeah this happens unfortunately all
the time in fact
you know i
have a staff of 19 reporters and editors
who i oversee the mother jones
washington dc bureau
and we're forever chasing things and i
often say if we get one out of 10 we're
doing pretty well
your reputation goes with each and every
story though doesn't it oh certainly i
mean and you know you
it only takes one story to land you in
the crapper um if you you know you're
rolling stone uva yeah you can have you
could have a great career of books and
stories and worked for you know you have
a great reputation as a newspaper a
magazine a website and you get something
wrong
and it's it's it's trouble it's what
people will remember and people lose
their jobs
over this and reporting like everything
else
uh
is is a is
an activity in which you can make
mistakes
you can get things wrong
but doing so in good faith
not everything that's wrong is done
wrong
purposefully to you know score a point
you just make a mistake
and
as that's hard when you do that in the
public eye and i think it's hard for
people to acknowledge
oftentimes acknowledge making mistake
but it's also hard to acknowledge that a
mistake was made for a non-devious
purpose
but yeah i mean i'm i've there are many
stories that i have done that i
you know fully believe in or that one of
my reporters has done and i just we
publish them and i just wait for
something to go wrong
so far it really hasn't happened but you
think and i always think okay look at
every fact here
is there something else that could be at
play here that we're not seeing
you know is there an alternative
explanation
um
because you know these days you know
they come at you we've been sued at
mother jones by people with a lot of
money we've we've won
those suits we have suits threatened
against us we did a story recently on a
russian oligarch and he threatened a
lawsuit against us
you know it was barely touched him i
mean but but any event you know we do
this you know
we saw what happened with gawker
one lawsuit basically took them out of
business
so
we do everything we can
we have a tremendous fact-checking
operation
uh at mother john's it's unlike what
happened at uh der spiegel
mr speaker they're german
um uh where where they had someone who
was making up stories so it happened
with stephen glass in the new republic
years ago you can google that if you
don't know what i'm referring to jason
up at the new york times yeah so it all
happens it happened with um
the washington post with janet cook
right
pulitzer yeah got a pulser so you know
we i you know i live in fear of making a
mistake or having some makeup have you
ever lived in fear of your life
no
ever been threatened
oh
on twitter by idiots
i mean i've never been out here in
washington i've never
you know
i'm sorry
it's just not house of cards it just
doesn't work that way i have you know
when i worked on the say people asked if
i was being followed when i'm doing the
russia stuff people ask if i'm being
intimidated by russian thugs
i've never
come up i mean i've been you know
threatened with lawsuits
but
not anything beyond that for the last
three hours we have been talking with
investigative journalist and author
david corn very quickly
blonde ghost was his first book about
ted shackley and the cia deep background
came out 99 it was a novel the lies of
george w bush and hubris came out during
the bush administration
showdown is the inside story of how
obama fought back
against boehner cantor and the tea party
we didn't get to spend enough time with
that i apologize and his most recent
along with michael isikoff russian
roulette the inside story of putin's war
on america and the election of donald
trump should let our audience know that
if they are in tucson you're going to be
at the tucson book fair
first weekend of march so which is
something we often cover live here on
book tv david corn thanks for being with
us i want to thank you for having me
i've been a tremendous fan of c-span
from the very beginning
and it's always been an honor to come on
and it's great to be on book tv and be
able to talk
beyond the sound bites that were often
forced into so
you know thank you very much peter
c-span where history unfolds